what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so after months of speculating after
months of postponements and so on
we're finally getting around to doing
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline and I am
so incredibly excited to bring this
storyline to you guys because I would
consider this to be one of the absolute
greatest stories to have ever been told
in the history of Marvel Comics and most
comic book readers in terms of Marvel or
even some people who read both DC and
Marvel would rate this as quite possibly
one of the top five story lines that
anybody needs to read who's interested
in getting into Marvel and there's a
couple reasons for this right now
it looks as though almost everything
that's taking place in Marvel Comics in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is moving
towards this event is moving towards
this this massive spacefaring adventure
involving Thanos and a multitude of
superheroes but the other side of this
coin is that a lot of the people that
we'll see in here we may not see just
because of the fact that Marvel doesn't
own the rights to these characters
namely the Silver Surfer who is a major
character in this story but what we're
also going to see with this Infinity
Gauntlet event is that we're gonna
follow two stories the first is going to
be a story involving Silver Surfer a
story involving his arrival up to the
point when he meets Doctor Strange and
the other one is going to involve the
stories of Jake and Ralph and band along
and we'll get into them later on when we
discuss what it is the characters have
to do with this Infinity Gauntlet event
but what we see as a story begins to
open up is that Doctor Strange is within
his Arcanum that he's simply just going
about his normal day and it seems here
that he's reading some kind of medical
journal that he's simply going over
whatever it is that he needs to read
here and this seems to be par for the
course when it comes to Doctor Strange
and this is just designed to introduce
us to a normal day to a peaceful day
well there's really nothing happening
but what we see is that there's some
kind of smash so it's not another kind
of a crash or a lot of explosion in
another room and Doctor Strange
immediately thinks that somebody's
breaking into his home that somebody's
trying to uh steal his artifacts but
when he arrives in the next room what he
sees is that the Silver Surfer is
appears to be unconscious
in his living room the Silver Surfer is
exhausted and for the most part
muttering to himself saying things like
he needs to reach dr. strange that he
must reach strange and what we see is a
dr. strange and long-held Silver Surfer
to the sofa and dr. strange tells him
that he has reached him that he has
reached dr. strange and Silver Surfer
says that he came to warn him came to
give him a a warning of a grave threat
and that the arrival could end could it
could herald the end of the universe and
that this person is Thanos that Thanos
is coming from here we switched to
Silver Surfer giving us a backstory on
what it was that that happened here and
and also were surfers really doing here
is explaining to us the events that led
up to the Thanos quest and the events
that took place between the Pharaohs
quest and the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline and what Silver Surfer tells
us here is that of course Thanos had
been tasked with eliminating half the
life in the universe by mistress death
which was the reason why he had gone on
the quest of gaining the infinity gems
in the first place so that he could
achieve this task he could perform this
task without a taking several lifetimes
to get before the task quite quickly and
do it in such a way that it would
satisfy the desire of mistress death and
what we see Silver Surfer telling us
here is that this is something this
Infinity Gauntlet the Thanos is in
possession of is something that could
destroy all of reality that could in the
entire universe and so something has to
be done here that because Thanos has
been ordered to end half the life in the
universe that forces need to be gathered
that the superheroes need to do
something otherwise everything could
come to an end
from here we switch to the perspective
of Thanos and Mephisto on some unknown
planet and we have previously talked
about Mephisto we've mentioned Mephisto
and again we're not going to go too in
depth into his character here but
Mephisto is a cosmic entity for the most
part an abstract of Karnes he's not
necessarily as powerful as Franklin
Richards for example but he is a very
powerful character in his own right but
given the fact that Thanos currently has
the Infinity Gauntlet
Mephisto really has no power that even
begins to compare to anything famous
Belov been mephisto while he initially
appears to be here as an ally while he
initially appears to be here as someone
who can provide small baubles of wisdom
for Thanos as he's learning how to use
this use this kind of power wisely and
effectively what we'll see is that
Mephisto actually has his own agenda
here he actually has his own plans and
his own mecha nations which will come to
fruition later on and what we see is
that Thanos is really talking to himself
more so than he's talking to Mephisto
but he says that when he initially went
on the quest when he initially started
this journey of gathering the infinity
gems that once the infinity gems were
gathered he felt as though he'd have a
million question that he would spend
more time pondering how to use this
power than actually using it and he says
that now he only really has one question
he says the question is how does he use
such power what does he do with such an
incredible power and he answers his own
question by saying that quite simply he
can do anything he wants to because he
is absolutely omnipotent he says that
for the most part if anything happens
that displeases him if an event takes
place that he doesn't like he can simply
undo it that he's completely incapable
of error than anything he wants is his
will and because it's as well
anything can happen he really presents
himself here as a God within the
universe and what I would like you guys
to take your a very particular note of
here is that Thanos is demonstrating
incredible arrogance that Thanos has
come across the Infinity Gauntlet and
believes himself to be absolute Lisa's
power to be absolutely incredible and
that no one can oppose him within the
universe and this will become very
important especially when we get towards
the end of the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline but what we see is a silver
surfer commenting on this silver surfer
is saying that that Thanos was too
arrogant to be anyone's servant to be
anyone's thrall and so what we see is
that Mephisto and Thanos transition back
to the lair of mistress death and we see
the Thanos as he approaches mistress
death begins to demonstrate to her
begins to tell her that he cares for her
that
that he loves her that the end that in
the end all this was done for her for
her love for her affection and that what
he wants to see here is that she
expressed that affection towards him
that she do something she say something
to indicate his presence but all we see
from mistress death at this point is
that she spurned Stannis is that she
turns Thanos away that she doesn't
return the affection that Thanos
demonstrates towards her now from here
we switched to the story of Jake Miller
Ralph
and Bambi long and what we see here is
that these individuals appear to simply
just be in the city there's really no I
guess context given to them they're at a
bar and they're simply just kind of
roaming around or maybe heading back
home and perhaps they were involved in
some kind of bank robber or they're
criminals of some kind or something like
that but what we see is that as these
individuals are travel or traveling to
their next location whatever that next
location happens to be that they end up
driving off a cliff they end up driving
to their deaths as explained to us by
whoever this narrator is that they don't
survive the fall and from here we switch
back to the story of the silver surfer
and what the silver surfers telling us
here is that during the time in which
they nose had gained the infinity gems
and between the current moment when he
is with dr. strange that he and Drax the
destroyer had attempted to stop Thanos
they did the best they could to thwart
Thanos but Thanos had demonstrated his
power to them and they were completely
helpless against him there was
absolutely nothing they could do to stop
him as he was warping all facets of
reality time-space the mine and so on
and so what we see is that Thanos strips
their spiritual essence from their
bodies and cash them into the soul Jim
into the spiritual world from here we
see that Silver Surfer says he
encountered someone named Adam warlock
and that Adam warlock appeared to be the
leader of the spiritual realm now this
is the first time that Silver Surfer has
ever actually come across Adam warlock
and this is the reason why as we know
who Adam warlock is the Silver Surfer
doesn't and so for him he doesn't know
what kind of power that Adam warlock
possesses he doesn't know the role that
Adam warlock possessor or plays within
the Marvel Universe and so what Silver
Surfer tells us here is that Adam
warlock casts a spell or uses his
abilities to eject the souls of the
Silver Surfer and Drax the destroyer
back into the physical world where they
have returned to their normal bodies and
what Silver Surfer tells us again is
that he immediately went on a quest to
travel to the planet Earth and to speak
with dr. strange and that the reason why
this was so important was because one
the power and the worldA Thanos has been
assigned by mistress death using the
Infinity Gauntlet and - and because of
the fact that sober surfer doesn't know
how much time has passed here he doesn't
know if he was trapped within the soul
gym for days or weeks or minutes or
seconds and so his immediate goal here
is to attract the attention of Doctor
Strange at this point we switch back to
the story of Jake Miller to Ralph and to
Bambi long and what we see is that this
narrator's telling us that the big guy
it seems to be the guy in charge had a
wave until things cooled down before
they all went in and what we see is that
three bright lights travel into the into
the spiritual world or into the physical
world and take over the bodies of Jake
Miller Bambi long and Ralph and we see
that Ralph is a little upset by this
Ralph reacts to this saying that this
body is totally destroyed these bodies
are dead and that they can't simply just
travel around looking like this that
they have to find some way to at the
very least be discreet and what we see
is that the person who is in possession
of Jake Miller's body says that his
powers are for healing and modifying
these bodies so that they can suit their
needs and so what we see is Jake Miller
saying that because of the fact that he
is the least injured that he will go
into the motel that they've come across
and secured their lodging from here we
see that Bambi long skin appears to be
turning green which of course seems to
be something that she's happy with
something that she very much much enjoys
at this point we travel back to the
story of Mephisto and Thanos within the
realm of mistress death and again all we
really see going on here is that
mistress death is simply continuing to
scorn Panos that she does not return the
infections that Thanos has demonstrated
towards her and she's constantly quiet
towards him she refuses to speak to him
she refuses to look at him that even if
she does look at him she looks at him
with a glance with a scornful glance and
simply just turns away and what we see
Thanos doing is trying to reason with
her Thanos is telling her that
previously before he gained the power of
the Infinity Gauntlet that he was simply
a servant towards her but now he is her
equal that she deserves better than a
servant she deserves some kind of a mate
and so Thanos abused himself as somebody
that could stand in the role of being a
being an equal but then we see his mind
and we see his arrogance begin to
demonstrate itself
and he says that he shouldn't just be an
equal to mistress death that he should
be superior to mistress death but what
we see is that one of the servants of
mistress death says that Thanos is in
possession of power that is so much
higher than what she has that she is no
longer anything in terms of a maid that
if she had a romantic if you return a
romantic interest in him she would be
more of a love slave than anything else
because he could force her to do
anything and so what we see is that
danos replies to this by saying that she
is the keeper of his heart that he loves
her with everything that he has
well this individual says this servant
says because of the power that he
possesses that his love is stifling that
his love is bondage that Allah says no
he says that his love is worship that
there should be shrines built to
mistress death that there should be
shrine to Bill to her greatness and so
what we see is that Thanos in the
vastness of space or in the depth of
space physically creates a shrine and
transports all of them to it which is
similar just Thanos using the reality
Jim for for his own end and this is for
the most part what we will see phallus
remained for the remainder of the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline we won't
really see Pharaoh's transition anywhere
go anywhere else except for this place
and this is very important because what
we'll see is a mass
then taking place we will see a
multitude of superheroes and cosmic
entities descend on this place and an
effort to stop Thanos and what we see
here is that Thanos tells mistress death
he has created this place for her now
this place is a is is is designed for
his adoration of her it is a shrine to
be built to the beauty of what he
perceives to be the idea of death we see
that he creates two chairs to sit side
by side with one another and that he and
mistress death will sit together for all
eternity and they will shape the future
of the universe they will make the
universe as they see fit they will
decide who lives and who dies they will
decide what's created and what's
destroyed but what we see is that
mistress death continues to spurn Thanos
as she continues to reject any
advancements that he makes they she
continues to reject any affection that
he demonstrates for her from here we see
that Thanos who uses his abilities with
the Infinity Gauntlet to do what he
considers to be yet another instance of
impressing mistress death and what he
does here is he brings back nebula
now nebula had previously presented
herself to Thanos as that as his
granddaughter as the granddaughter of
Thanos and Danice had taken her on as
his charge but eventually the time came
when Thanos realized that she was
aligned that she was not his
granddaughter that she was simply just a
space pirate and so what we see pharaohs
doing is warping her body transforming
her body and turning her into a corpse
more or less she's neither truly alive
nor truly dead she's just a corpse and
she could never really experienced
anything other than absolute pain and
the inability to stop that pain as well
as the inability to simply die and
Famous does this as a creation for
mistress death he does this to I guess
as a common of sorts on the perversion
of life and the beauty of death but what
we see is that mistress death appears to
be appalled by this she appears to be
absolutely disgusted by this and so she
again turns her back on Thanos from here
we see that I was getting angry with
mistress death denison screams at her he
yells at her not
turned her back on him that she needs to
face him and what we see is this servant
begins to speak again with Thanos and
says that that these empty boats that
he's making that these disdainful
actions that he's committing are not
impressing mistress death they are not
not pleasing mistress death
and so we see fan OHS destroys this
servant from here Thanos completely
shows a I guess not necessarily a 180 in
terms of his affection of mistress death
but his anger with mistress death and
saying that she will either speak to him
directly or not at all and what we see
is if Thanos continues to be angry but
we also see Mephisto playing on this
role of Thanos we see
Mephisto playing on this this this anger
the Pharaohs has four mistress death and
what he says is that perhaps it's
something that Thanos hasn't done the
role that Thanos hasn't fulfilled and
this is when Thanos realized that he has
not done what mistress death asked him
to do the Thanos has not eliminated half
the life in the universe and so what we
see going on here is one of the single
most memorable moments in the history of
comic books when we see Thanos apologize
to mistress death we see Thanos saying
that he's sorry that he realizes she's
angry with him because his behavior has
been inexcusable that rather than doing
performing the task that she had
assigned him that he had refused to do
it or simply ignored it and then didn't
understand why it was a she was angry in
the first place and so what we see is
that Mephisto shocked to see that this
will actually happen and Thanos walks to
the edge of the shrine and snaps his
fingers and when Thanos snaps his
fingers it results and half the life in
the universe being totally eradicated
from here we switch to spider-man and
spider-man is traveling through New York
City he's simply swinging from one
building to another and it's his normal
night in terms of looking around to see
if there's any kind of crime going on
and for the most part he says that he
was that he's calling it a night that
he's bringing this to an end and that
he's heading home but then a sudden wave
of vertigo hits him and it seems as
though his spider sense is going totally
awry from there there's a reaction to
everybody people are freaking out
because people are simply just vanished
that people are simply just disappearing
off the face of the planet but nobody
knows why and what we see here is that
spider-man begins to freak out
spider-man understands what it is is
taking place that people are simply
vanishing that people are simply
disappearing that no one knows where
they're disappearing - and his fear here
is that Mary Jane may be one of these
individuals who have vanished and so
what we see is Spider Man flying offer
us swinging off to get back to his
apartment so that he can find out
whether or not Mary Jane is safe from
here we transition to Captain America
and Captain America is within the
Avengers headquarters and of course he's
going about his normal routine again of
just verifying that the premise is safe
making sure that everything's okay and
for the most part he doesn't really seem
it doesn't really seem as though
anything to majors happening we see that
Hawkeye along with Siri are handing
Captain America some documents talking
about various things that are taking
place in the world at the moment but
then we see that mid-conversation that
Circe and Hawkeye vanish they just
totally disappear in Captain America
couldn't could absolutely do nothing to
stop this he was terrified he was
horrified because for him he knew that
some that whatever force was at work
here that whatever had happened that had
done this that had forced these
superheroes to disappear was far beyond
anything that he was capable of stopping
and so he knew that this was going to
turn into something big this was going
to turn into something massive something
they could possibly be a threat to the
universe as a whole from here we switch
to Nick Fury and Nick Fury is within the
shield Helicarrier and what we see Nick
Fury doing is simply going over
documentation going over the information
that's been given to him about how half
the Earth's population is simply just
vanished that there's nothing as far as
their investigations and shield goes
that indicates what could possibly
happen here there are no mutants that
have any sort of power that could do
this as far as they understand or even
if they do have that kind of power now
they haven't exercised it there's really
nothing going on here in terms of any
energy projections they've demonstrated
coming from the planet Earth that would
explain why it is that half of the life
on the planet has simply just vanished
from here we see this coming beginning
to come to a
close and what we see is that we touch
back with Ralph Bambi long and and Jacob
Miller and what we see is that Ralph and
Mandy long or Bambi long are simply just
within the hotel room that Ralph is
commenting that he likes being back in
the physical world that he likes
returning here and Bambi is simply just
getting used to her having her physical
body but what we see is that Bambi
disappears as as ralph is looking at her
that she simply just vanishes and ralph
begins to panic
ralph doesn't know what to do here and
so what we see is that ralph runs to the
next room and he tries to tell Jacob
Miller that Bambi is simply vanished
that he doesn't know where she went to
but what we see is that in place of Jake
Miller is a cocoon indicating to us that
Adam warlock is returning to the
physical universe so as we continue with
part two of the Infinity Gauntlet what
we see is that we're picking up with dr.
strange here and again what's taken
place up to this point is that the great
disappearance has taken place as it's
referred to in the comics that half the
population on the planet Earth as well
as the universe has simply just been
blinked out of existence and so what
we'll see for the most part is virtual
panic we'll see a lot of superheroes
trying to deal with this trying to cope
with this element of what it is has
taken place both on the planet Earth and
beyond and what we see with dr. strange
here is that he's gone to consult dr.
Hank Pym Hank Pym has arrived at a
doctor Strange's mansion and the goal
here is to try to find some way to
restore the silver surfer back to health
but because of his alien physiology
because of the fact that he doesn't
require any kind of nourishment to
survive it's kind of a coin flip here in
terms of what they can do in order to to
restore him or perhaps us something that
he's just healing himself and what we
see is that hank pym says that he's done
the best he can up to this point that
given the alien physiology of the Silver
Surfer that he's done everything he
knows and that all they can do is simply
just wait but what he also says is that
he has to return to the West Coast
Avengers due to what's happened with the
disappearance in order to assist him as
best he can and the Doctor Strange may
also want to go on to contact the
original Avengers and let them know
what's going on here
but what we see is that as Hank ran
begins to leave doctor Doctor Strange
seems to be stuck in place he seems to
be kind of frozen in place and one of
his servants attempts to shake him out
of it the Doctor Strange appears to be
falling into a trance and what we see is
that his spirit is more or less torn
away from his body that it is taken to a
place that seems to exist beyond the
physical realm perhaps in some sort of
soul maybe a middle ground or something
like that but what we see is that some
unnamed individual some sort of energy
force has drawn dr. Strange's essence to
him and what he tells dr. strange when
he asks what it is that he's doing here
who this individual is is that he's here
to help save this reality from the
insanity of Thanos but that he can't do
it by himself dr. strange replies by
saying that if this individual wants him
to gather up all these superheroes and
all these righteous individuals for a
conflict then he needs to do something
to demonstrate who he is because these
individuals most likely will not simply
just unite under the single banner of a
person that they know nothing about and
what we see this person saying is that
he can open his soul he can is expose
his soul directly to the soul of Doctor
Strange but the issue here is that
because both of their souls will be
exposed to one another that there is an
inherent danger here that one of them
could be destroyed or that they could
meld into a single person dr. strange
says this is a risk that he wouldn't
normally take but because of the grave
nature of the circumstances that he will
do whatever he needs to get any kind of
help he can and so what we see is that
both of these individual souls are sort
of combined into water at the very least
they're able to look into each other
Souls and when dr. strange looks into
the soul of this unnamed individual he
develops complete and total trust he now
believes him and in trusting him
implicitly and says that he will do
anything he needs to in order to assist
this individual in any way that he can
from here we switched to dr. doom and
what we see is a dr. doom is using his
various technology and instrumentation
at his disposal to
is the origin to trace the location of
the disappearance and he traces the
energies that cause the grace
disappearance on to the other side of
the of the galaxy on the far side of the
Milky Way galaxy and so the information
that he has here is that one he knows
where it is but that - he's also
recognizing some kind of phenomena that
seems to be very similar to the energies
that caused the elimination of half a
life in the universe and that this
phenomena is is emanating from the
residence of Doctor Strange and so what
we see dr. Doom's saying here is that
this is his universe this is these are
his people on the planet Earth and that
no one has the right to go in and to
effectively begin wreaking havoc without
either speaking with him directly or
somehow asking for his assistance or
involving him in some manner and so we
see dr. doom undertaking the task of
finding out what it is that has gone on
here but dr. doom again also has his own
motives here because he sees this as a
chance to expand his own power given the
great power that was used for this grow
this this vast disappearance and to also
expand his scientific knowledge and so
this for the most part is the biggest
reason why he's here and we'll see that
play out when we get to the actual
conflict on the shrine of death out in
space later on and the Infinity Gauntlet
story from here we transition to Drax
the destroyer eros and Fire Lord on
Titan and what we know here is that
mentor who was the father of Eros and
and Thanos is one of the individuals who
has vanished from the universe and what
we see is that Isaac again the the
autonomous computer system within the
the fortress of Titan so to speak is
informing eros and Fire Lord and Drax
the destroyer that this is all a
universal act that this is all taking
place across the universe that it's not
simply confined to Titan it's not simply
confined to the Milky Way galaxy that
all life and the universe has simply
vanished
we then see that eros simply just
disappears but what we know here is that
eros is not one of the individuals who
has simply vanished due to the great
vanishing because this has already taken
place what we see is that
eros has been taken by Thanos Thanos
presumably using the space gym has
transported eros to his location and
eros realizes that Thanos is in
possession of the power gems now what
heroes tells us here is that he's
familiar with the infinity gems he's
familiar with what it is that they can
do now how familiar he is with them is
something that Marvel doesn't explain he
simply just tells us that he knows what
they are and he recognizes that with all
of them on a single gauntlet with all of
them being wielded by one individual
that this individual possesses a power
that is virtually unrivaled within the
main earth-616 Marvel Universe and so
what we see is that eros begins to look
around and he recognizes Mephisto but he
also recognizes mistress death he
recognizes nebula who's simply just
walking around as a corpse who is
walking in this fine line between life
and death
Thanos says that this is a family
reunion that he has restored nebula or
that he's brought nebula to him more or
less poking fun at the fact that she had
presented herself as a granddaughter to
him falsely then he also says that his
mate that his lover here presumably
playing the role of his wife is mistress
death and that Mephisto is simply here
as an advisor
eros asks why mentor isn't here and
Thanos replies that mentor wasn't
invited nor will he be and he says that
he intentionally ensured that eros oh
I'm sorry that mentor was one of the
individuals who was eliminated during
the Great vanishing that he made sure
that he was one of the people who was
simply just blinked out of existence and
the reason why is because mentor would
attempt to find a way to take the
Infinity Gauntlet from Thanos he would
try to find some way to bring this
conquest to an end and would be one of
the few individuals in the Marvel
Universe that would probably be able to
do it not in the sense of sheer raw
power but in the sense that he would be
able to organize forces in such a way
that he would be able to achieve this
act but what that Oh says is that
ultimate power is now his that he can
reshape the universe with it and that
nothing can interfere with this mission
what we see heroes doing here is playing
on this gyro says that if this is what
Thanos wants then nothing will interfere
that he will do everything he can to
help Thanos as best
but what we see Pharaohs realizing here
is that eros is using his powers to
manipulate emotions on Thanos and so
Thanos simply says how how poignant how
powerful and charming can arrest be when
he can't talk and so he takes eros his
mouth away from here we see that uh
saying that this is how all things shall
be from this point forward anything that
irritates Thanos will simply just cease
to be at this point we switch back to
Captain America and what we get here is
more or less a list not a full list but
a pretty significant list of which
superheroes have gone missing as a
result of the great vanishing and this
is a pretty important list and the
reason why is because throughout this
conflict a lot of you guys will ask
questions like where is Hercules where
is Archangel where is the Invisible
Woman the Fantastic Four where is nigh
Thrasher or The Vindicator from Alpha
Flight you guys will ask a lot of these
different questions on where these
superheroes are and so what Marvel has
done is they've laid out some of the
more significant members of the x-men
the Avengers Alpha Flight and various
other superhero teams that were
relatively popular at the time this
story was written and simply said
they're just not here anymore they've
simply just been among the individuals
who have been blinked out of existence
and so what we see here is that Captain
America she-hulk
and the man standing in the place of
Thor Eric Masterson analyzing all this
information now this idea of Eric
Masterson is something that I would like
you to keep in the back of your head
because this again is not the real Thor
now the the story in terms of how it is
at Eric Masterson begins to undertake
the role of Thor and how he takes uh
takes over this role for a pretty good
amount of time there's a very very good
story so I'd like to do that justice and
we'll talk about that when we actually
get into our discussion of Thor after we
finish various characters when Infinity
Gauntlet is over but for the most part
all we need to do is so we just be aware
the fact that this is not Thor Odin's
son this is simply just Eric Masterson
and what we see is that all these
individuals are focusing on the fact
that things are for the most part very
very bad that Eric Masterson is trying
to undertake the role of Thor trying to
speak like Thor trying to ensure that
he's passed office Thor but that
everybody else is trying to deal with
the fact that some of the most prominent
superheroes in the Marvel community are
just gone
at this point we switched to Odin and
what we see is that Odin is an Asgard
and he's wearing the the ceremonial
eyepatch of sorrow now this is something
that a lot of people get confused in the
the movie of Thor we saw that that
Anthony Hopkins was wearing an eyepatch
the eye patch is worn as a ceremonial
thing it's not something that Odin
actually has to wear he hasn't actually
lost an eye
and for the most part what we see here
is that Odin has called together the sky
fathers now the sky fathers are what we
would consider to be the old gods these
are people like Zeus Osiris of Egypt
these are what we would look at to say
that older parts of society older parts
of the world generations and thousands
of years ago these were the people these
were the gods that ancient humanity
worshipped but in the Marvel Universe
these are actual beings these are true
beings they may have been forgotten over
the years they may no longer be
worshipped by people over the years but
it doesn't take away from the fact that
they are real and they have a vast
amount of power and as these individuals
form under the name of the sky father
have of the sky fathers they have a
significant amount of power and what
Onan does here is Odin calls them
together band them together and says
that because of this great power because
of this great threat that they need to
fight together in order to try to defeat
Thanos but for the most part this would
be a laughable conquest at best because
the sky fathers despite their vast power
have absolutely no ability to thwart the
power of Thanos at all in any way from
here we transitioned the Windell von to
quasar and always see with this bit of
the story is that quasar has simply
arrived to a predestined or a
pre-arranged set of coordinates by epoch
and what he simply says here is that
he's just supposed to wait that quasar
simply just supposed to hold out here
that he's not supposed to do anything
until he's instructed - from here we
switch back to the story of Ralph who is
now undertaken the role of pip the troll
and for the most part pip the troll is
just the sidekick of Adam warlock and so
all this really does is confirm that
Adam warlock is now becoming he's now
rejoining the the physical Marvel
Universe and what we see pip the troll
here doing is simply just waiting for
Adam warlock to wake out to come out of
his cocoon and as he's waiting there's
some kind of an explosion in the next
room that throws him out of his seated
position and into the TV or simply just
to a different part of the room and when
the explosion ends he gets up and he
goes into the next room and asked this
individual since they can't stay here
any more where it is that they're
supposed to go and this individual
replies by saying after Thanos from here
we switched back to Doctor Doom at the
residence of Doctor Strange and what we
see is that the Silver Surfer has now
woken up he's now come to and dr. doom
has his doombots restraining Doctor
Strange and what we see is Doctor
Strange pleading with dr. doom saying
that he is meddling in dangers that he
doesn't really understand he doesn't
really know what's going on here but
what we see is that the Silver Surfer
tries to to stop Doctor Doom he tries to
overpower dr. doom but dr. doom uses his
power to overpower the Silver Surfer now
under normal circumstances this would
not happen
dr. doom would not be able to overpower
the Silver Surfer despite his vast power
but the Silver Surfer is in a weakened
position here he's he's very very weak
and so he doesn't have his full physical
strength otherwise he would easily be
able to stop dr. doom from here we see
that dr. doom turns his power against
Doctor Strange and what he wants to know
is what's happened here he wants to know
everything that has taken place as far
as this great disappearance and the
forces behind it now Doctor Strange
initially doesn't say anything Doctor
Strange initially doesn't speak but what
we see is that before Doctor Strange can
say anything there's an explosion behind
them and we see that dr. doom the Silver
Surfer and Doctor Strange all look
around at this point we see Adam warlock
has arrived and Adam warlock simply just
replies by saying that in his time he
was called Adam warlock and that they
may also do so if they feel inclined
from here we switch back to Thanos and
what we see is that Thanos is using the
power of the Infinity Gauntlet to more
or less either psychologically or
possibly even physically torture eros
and nebula and again he's doing this as
a way to satisfy to please mistress
death but mistress death doesn't really
seem to find this the slightest bit
interesting she doesn't find it at all
satisfying it's simply just something
she pays no attention to or doesn't
really give any kind of of credence to
from here we see eros after the torture
is ended looking at Thanos and coming to
this realization that the Infinity
Gauntlet has driven Thanos insane that
this power has driven him out of his
mind and that on a whim
due to his insanity he could simply just
eliminate the universe and so this is
when when eros really grasps what it is
is going on here and grasp the danger of
this situation from here we transitioned
back to Adam warlock and Doctor Strange
dr. doom and the Silver Surfer and what
we see Adam warlock saying is more or
less explaining how it was that Thanos
was able to gain the Infinity Gauntlet
how it was that he was able to to gain
this fast power and that he's arrived
here in order to help bring an end to
these schemes
dr. strange realizes that Adam warlock
was the one that communicated with him
earlier when he came to this
understanding of what it meant to
undertake the role of uniting all of
these superheroes we also see dr. doom
commenting and saying that this is a set
of circumstances whose peril whose
danger almost rivals that of the coming
of the Beyonder now dr. doom says that
it does rival the coming of the Rionda
but there's a vast difference here the
Beyonder had power that dwarfed anything
that the Infinity Gauntlet could do he
was from an entirely different universe
entirely different multiverse and he had
incredible power and could do pretty
much anything that he wanted to but
we'll talk more about him again when we
get into the Secret Wars 1 & 2 and the
Beyonder but what we see is that Adam
warlock says that this is going to be
difficult this is going to be a fight
that will very well cost the lives of
some individuals and will require 100%
of everybody because it's going to
they're basically going to be going and
going against forces that are going to
require cunning and guile to defeat as
opposed to simply sheer power from here
we see that dr. doom challenges Adam
warlock and asks him by what right it is
that he claims the mantle of leadership
Adam warlock replies here by saying that
he is the one who battled Thanos
previously that he's the one that knows
the secrets of the inner workings of the
infinity gems and so with that knowledge
he's the only one that's really equipped
to combatant Thanos he's really the only
one capable of going against Thanos and
successfully being able to organize
forces in an effective way to where
things can be defeated at this point we
see Doctor Doom more or less counting
his losses and just kind of accepting
this and sort of moving forward but what
we'll see is that again this is not
necessarily acquiescence by dr. doom so
much as it is dr. doom just biding his
time what we also see is the Silver
Surfer commenting on whether or not Adam
warlock is truly the person that should
lead them that is Adam warlock really
the best choice here that Adam warlock
seems vastly different from the Adam
warlock that he had met in the soul
world and so because no one really knows
anything about him
no one really knows anything about his
motivations other than what he claims
his motivations to be from here we
transitioned back to Thanos and again we
see that us manipulating reality to
torture eros and nebula and again he's
becoming extremely angry here he's
becoming extremely frustrated because
mistress death will not acknowledge him
mistress death will not return his
affections and we see him yelling at her
we see him screaming at her asking what
it is that it would take to please her
that he's done everything that she's
asked he's given her the entire universe
that he would do anything in order to
make her love him that all he asks here
is that she simply just used her voice
and speak his name aloud and that would
be enough and so what we see is that
Thanos in his anger lets off an energy
blast he lets off this massive force of
energy in all directions and what we see
is it the first thing that encounters or
that is encountered by this energy blast
is a twenty million year old red giant
and what this red giant does is simply
just destroy somebody just explodes and
that's the end of it from here we see
some kind of spaceship traveling through
the through the cosmos and the planet
that the spaceship is approaching is
destroyed and we see an individual here
telling us that the wrath of Thanos the
Supreme Being is is something to behold
that this planet is the second planet to
be destroyed as this being was traveling
to it that is the second banquet that
has been robbed from him and what we see
is that this person is Galactus and
Galactus is again attempting to satiate
his hunger but also recognizes that the
vast power the Thanos has here is
something that cannot be ignored
that is that it's going to require that
Galactus go through the process of
bringing together a multitude of forces
in terms of the cosmic entities in order
to attempt to bring an end to the power
that Thanos has here and that the issue
here is that the emanations that are
being released here that the power that
is being displayed here by Thanos will
reach the planet Earth and that it will
only contain about two percent of its
power but it will be a mass of a
energy nonetheless and so what we see is
that we transition to the planet Earth
and we see that cloak who is one half of
the team cloak-and-dagger is by himself
that dagger is gone she is one of the
individuals who had simply been blinked
out of existence and that the cloak
feels as though because his other half
is gone that while they were linked
while they were kind of like two halves
as the whole as he describes it that he
doesn't really feel like he has a reason
to go on but what we see is that he
finds this reason to continue as this
force that was admitted by Thanos
reaches the planet Earth and shakes the
entire planet crumbling several cities
and wiping out the Japanese islands and
of course we see that cloak uses his
ability to to save various humans to
save them from their impending deaths of
falling off buildings or else being
crushed by rubble from this point we
transition back to dr. strange silver
surfer dr. doom and Adam warlock and
what we see here is that these
individuals are trying to deal with the
aftermath of this they're trying to
understand the aftermath of what's gone
on here that the power the Thanos has
demonstrated despite being on the other
side of the galaxy there's a power that
most of them couldn't really even fathom
and that it will take an incredible
organization and incredible upheaval for
all of them to be able to go sexes
successfully go toe-to-toe with fan oohs
and so what we see is a comment here we
see the question being asked what was
that what was that energy blast from
here we're going to bring an end to this
video and in the next video we're going
to pick up with battle formations
preparations for war and we'll see that
we're more or less seeing superheroes
being organized we're seeing superheroes
being brought together by Adam warlock
as they begin the preparations for
taking on Thanos
so as we begin our discussion on
Infinity Gauntlet issue number three I
think you guys are really going to enjoy
this comic and the reason why is because
what we'll see taking place over the
course of this are battle formations
preparations for war we're going to be
seeing a plan put together and it won't
be until the end of the comic that we
actually understand the true nature of
this plan but what this is is also the
last issue where we have talking and
it'll be the last issue before we
actually get into the main discussion
the main conflict that takes place
between Thanos and all of these
superheroes leading up to the end of the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline and what we
see here as the story begins to pick up
is that we're back with dr. doom Adam
warlock the Silver Surfer and Doctor
Strange and dr. doom is commenting on
how he agrees picking up immediately
from the last discussion that now is the
time for action but Adam warlock says no
Adam warlock says there are forces at
work here that dr. doom just doesn't
understand that he just can't possibly
grasp and that rushing into action like
this would almost guarantee certain doom
and so he says that he has a intricate
and a very inner weaved plan that's
unfolding here and that the slightest
disturbance could very well lead to the
ruin of all what we also see Doctor
Strange commenting is saying that he
agrees with with Adam warlock that they
have to trust him that dr. doom that
Silver Surfer they have to come to this
understanding that Adam warlock knows
what he's doing that tremendous powers
are gaining here for this final
confrontation and he more or less
repeats the words of Adam warlock here
saying that that premature action could
lead to total destruction and so dr.
doom acquiesce is dr. doom says that
it's driving him nuts waiting to take
action but that for the time being he's
willing to put this off he's willing to
go ahead and hold things now from here
we see Adam warlock saying that it's
time to make preparations that it's time
to go about the business of moving to
the towards the next step of his master
plan and so he calls on dr. strange and
what we see Doctor Strange doing is a
teleporting Adam warlock Doctor Doom and
the Silver Surfer to the
headquarters and at the Avengers
headquarters we have she-hulk Captain
America and Thor and they're trying to
come to an understanding of what's going
on here they're trying to deal again as
a follow-up to the last video of what's
happened since the disappearance of
various superheroes but when Adam
warlock and Doctor Doom and Doctor
Strange and the Silver Surfer up here
the immediate idea is that Doctor
Strange is keeping strange company that
he is with people who he would never
normally form an alliance with but what
we see is that immediately Adam warlock
and Doctor Strange begin to convince
she-hulk
Thor and Captain America that the
situation is so dire that Doctor Doom is
not here to fight against them the
Doctor Doom is here to fight with them
and so when the question is asked what
the intention is here for Adam warlock
why it is that he's here and why it is
is such strange alliances have been
formed out of warlock replies by simply
saying that they're raising an army from
here we transition to Black Widow and
black widow doesn't necessarily give us
a huge in-depth discussion here but
because black widows part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I felt it would be
relevant to include her in this
discussion and know we really see is
that she's one of the people on the
sidelines she's kind of in the
background she's doing the best she can
to help save lives as a result of the
energy shockwave that had reached the
planet Earth and a devastation that it
had caused we see that she's jumping out
of a building out of a burning building
saving a baby and for the most part this
is kind of what we would expect to see
with her character because she doesn't
really have any superpowers she's just
more or less a super spy with all kinds
of gadgets at her disposal but then we
switch and we see that there is a woman
who is falling out of a building who's
hanging on for dear life and Black Widow
goes with an attempt to try to save her
but the building collapses and crumbles
before Black Widow can get there and so
again this is jim Starlin this is marvel
injecting a little bit of realism here
and saying that with with stories like
these with comics like these that not
everybody makes it out the other side
that not everybody survives and so what
we see is that this woman who was
tumbling to her death did in fact die
that she was crushed by the rebel and
the degree of
and even if not necessarily crushed she
was certainly burned to death and the
way that we see a see black widow
dealing with this I think is a great
testament to the the human nature of her
character the difference between her and
a lot of other superheroes that you see
in the Marvel community where she just
can't accept the fact that it's enough
she says that it's not enough that her
best just simply isn't enough here from
here we switched to Doctor Strange and
Adam warlock and what we see Doctor
Strange doing is calling upon
superheroes calling upon various
individuals to gather - to bring their
powers with them due to the necessity of
them and their powers with regards to
the upcoming conflict and the first two
people that we see arriving here are our
Iron Man and spider-man from here we
switch to the arrival of new characters
we see of course Wolverine coming here
we see Drax the destroyer and again Drax
the destroyer serves the purpose of I
guess trying to are being able to hunt
down and attract Thanos no matter where
he is in the cosmos but due to the fact
that Adam warlock has Silver Surfer on
his side and silver surfer has cosmic
awareness it's really not the ability of
Drax to locate Thanos that they're
interested in it's the sheer raw power
that he possesses that they're
interested in who we also see showing up
here is Fire Lord now again we haven't
done a big discussion on fire Lord
but Fire Lord was one of the heralds of
Galactus and so for the most part he was
one of the individuals who served the
same purpose as the Silver Surfer the
next person we see showing up is Nova of
the New Warriors and this is due to the
fact that Nova is the only one at this
moment who is able to tap into the full
might of the Nova force and so for him
for for Adam warlock and Silver Surfer
and the opposing forces Nova is really a
necessity here he's someone they
absolutely need the next person here is
Namor the Submariner and of course
neighbor the Submariner has a super
strength although for the most part in
terms of his relation to characters like
Drax a destroyer
even The Incredible Hulk he's not all
that strong but his military his ability
to to plan tactics his military
experience and the conquest that he's
had over the
his life will definitely be an asset to
this team the next person we see is
cloaked and again all Koch really does
here serve the purpose of being someone
that can teleport people over distances
now to my knowledge I don't think Marvel
has ever established the fact that cloak
can teleport people over an infinite
amount of distance and so they're not
really looking for cloak here to be
someone to teleport everybody all the
way to the other side of the galaxy to
fight Thanos
they simply have him here because he
could be an individual that could
teleport groups of people around or
could do serve some kind of purpose or
possibly he could even swallow Thanos
entirely from here we see the remaining
members of this group coming together we
see Cyclops of x-factor because remember
at this time the x-men were a different
group it was giant-size x-men an
x-factor was composed of the original
x-men team and the Wayne appears to us
here is that of the either original
members of the x-men or the current
members of the x-men Wolverine and
Cyclops seem to be the only ones who
were left alive or at the very least the
only ones who were called upon we also
see the Scarlet Witch arriving here to
meet with the vision we see the
Incredible Hulk
being invited but the Incredible Hulk
doesn't actually show up at first and
the reason why the Incredible Hulk
doesn't show up as eyes explained to us
by Tony Stark is because the Avengers
had previously turned their back on on
the Incredible Hulk due to the fact that
much like we saw with the Illuminati
where he was exiled from the planet
Earth The Incredible Hulk was deemed too
dangerous for himself he was out of
control and so the Avengers hadn't
necessarily abandoned him entirely but
they had a more or less kind of Hannegan
his hat and shunted him out but what we
see Iron Man and Captain America saying
here is that if he's reformed he can be
one of the Avengers again he can come
back The Incredible Hulk overhears this
and says that'll be enough for now and
so he joins the group of superheroes who
are coming to fight against the forces
of Thanos and what Adam warlock tells us
here is that this army is now complete
and so the individuals that we see that
have arrived here appear to be the only
the individuals who were either left or
have been invited to become part of this
for here we see Captain America speaking
directly to the forces that have
gathered in Captain America says that
everybody is here to fight the forces of
Thanos to fight against Thanos as his
against his Infinity Gauntlet and what
we see dr. Doom's saying is that before
Captain America goes any further that
the question has to be asked here is
Adam warlock the best person to lead
this group Doctor Strange replies by
asking there's no real discussion here
this is pretty much all there is so
there's no two ways about it
but dr. doom says that he's the only
person that has the ruthlessness the
cunningness and the guile to lead this
group and of course for the most part
everybody is against him on this Captain
America says no way The Scarlet Witch
spider-man Eric Masterson they all say
that this is not the case and so Captain
America replies to Doctor Strange simply
saying that deep down inside I'm sorry
Doctor Doom he knows that that atom or
Lex the only one that can really stop
Thanos that Adam warlock is the only one
that can really lead them to victory and
so Doctor Doom simply acquiesce is again
and says okay at this point we see that
Adam warlock says that there's going to
be yet another gathering that these are
the only individuals that have showed up
here but that he's also coming together
with more allies and when the question
is asked what these allies are Adam
warlock simply replies by saying cosmic
allies indicating to us that he's also
gathering the cosmic entities together
as a force to fight against the power of
Thanos what we also see is that Adam
warlock and the Silver Surfer travel to
the other side to the far corner of the
galaxy and the reason for this as we'll
pick up is that their meeting with
quasar and the cosmic entities in order
to form a team in order to come together
for the purpose of bringing everybody
together to fight against the power of
Thanos and when they arrive that's
exactly what they're what we're told
what we're told is that Eon I'm sorry
that epoch informed some Adam warlock
that all the cosmic entities had simply
been waiting for him they were simply
waiting for him to arrive
and when he does we see that almost all
of them are gathered here now there are
some cosmic entities it on here but for
the most part almost all of them or the
most prominent ones are we see Cronus we
see the Living Tribunal we see master
order and Lord chaos the stranger and of
course this is a list that we had
previously discussed so we won't go into
it too much longer
but two of the most notable members here
that I would like you to pay attention
to our eternity and the Living Tribunal
and the reason why as is explained to us
is because more or less what they're
calling together here is a trial with a
living tribunal overseen and the whole
reason for this is because again the
Living Tribunal exists to ensure the
cosmic balance is in place that no one
forced becomes such a threat to its
universe that it could result in the
destruction of that universe or other
universes should its dangers spill over
and what we see eternity saying here is
that he is the embodiment of all that is
of everything within the universe and
that that Thanos attempts to usurp this
position from him The Living Tribunal
says that he's considered this matter
but that he cannot interfere and the
reason why is because Thanos only
strives to replace eternity as the the
embodiment of all reality and the
natural selection is one of the oldest
truths that the strong replaced the weak
and that if eternity isn't strong enough
to oppose someone who wants to challenge
him and take his place
then eternity should perish and the new
force should take its place and so the
Living Tribunal says that he cannot
interfere that he will not become
involved in this matter and this is a
very big issue here and the reason why
is because if the Living Tribunal had
ruled on the side of eternity when the
Living Tribunal simply could have
arrived at Thanos location and blinked
him out of existence despite the power
the Thanos had or he could have simply
just stripped him of the Infinity
Gauntlet because as we discuss with our
discussion in the on the Living Tribunal
as a lead-up to the Thanos quest and the
Infinity Gauntlet event we had talked
about how during the during the Infinity
Crusade during the the Infinity watch
storyline that Adam warlock had
approached the Living Tribunal and
tribunal after seeing the power that
Adam warlock possessed and the anger
that he had displayed had simply just
eliminated all the power of the Infinity
Gauntlet within that vicinity from here
we see that the Eternity is more or less
leaving that he's kind of going off on
his own now what why he's doing this and
what he's doing is actually something
that we don't know and we won't see him
again for quite some time but what we
see is Adam warlock saying that it
doesn't matter that eternity is not here
what he says is that all of them are
here so that they can fight together so
that all these cosmic entities can
gather and oppose the force of Thanos
but then we see The Watcher saying that
he cannot be counted among these
individuals that will fight against
Thanos that he is a watcher and due to
his creed he is unable to interfere that
he can simply he can only observe and
record and so we see that the watcher
leaves from there if we see Santos
officer we see a Galactus challenging
Adam warlock Adam warlock says it easier
to lead all of them into an attack
against Thanos but Galactus says why
should they follow one such as him into
battle and so what we see is Adam
warlock saying that he is here for the
purpose of that that he's here for the
purpose of leading them into the
conflict and that's the only thing the
lactis needs to concern himself about
Galactus says that he does not heed
empty words from from mortals from
people that he considers to be beneath
him and Adam warlock simply replies by
saying Galactus is a fool from here we
see Galactus attempts to destroy Adam
warlock that he blasts him with a vast
amount of energy the light justdidn't
begins to talk with his his fellow
cosmic entities here and simply say that
they've gathered that their forces it
should be enough to defeat Thanos but
then we see that Adam warlock is
actually alive Adam warlock is on the
helmet of Galactus and asks him since
when it was that Galactus allowed the
the his anger and his his wrath to more
or less override his judgment the
Galactus is known for being one of the
most logical beings in the universe and
that surely Galactus can can determine
surely he can find here that the power
the entire my
of all these cosmic entities put
together is still insufficient for
defeating fan oohs and so we see that
master order Lord chaos and various
other cosmic entities band together
against Galactus and say that they are
siding with Adam warlock from here we
transition back to to thinness at the
shrine of death and what we see that is
saying is that his enemies are coming
for him that his enemies are going to
attempt to destroy him and he asked
mistress death that she will stand by
his side but mistress death again
spurned Thanos and she seems to turn her
back on him and then oh simply replies
by saying this is exactly as he had
expected that he had deluded himself
into believing that she could ever
really care for him and so he says that
being a Supreme Being means that he has
no need to suffer in a void of affection
that he does not have to go alone that
he does not have to rule without
mistress death that with all power all
things are possible and so what he does
is create a being named her Axia and tur
axia is as he describes that everything
mistress death is not that she's
everything that Thanos longs for that
she is the love that he wants from
mistress death that she is a
representation of what he considers to
be beautiful and he says that he's
there's really no need here there's no
need for mistress death anymore that
Thanos found has found his one true mate
but what we see is that this isn't true
that Thanos doesn't really believe this
that Thanos is more or less still in
love with the idea of mistress death and
is still angry at the fact that she will
not return his affection from here we
see that Adam warlock is preparing
forces he's preparing these superheroes
for the roles that they're going to have
to face he says that the battle that's
coming there's going to be fierce and
it's going to be awesome and that it may
very well cost the lives of several
superheroes but that that's the price
that they have to pay
he says the Doctor Strange has conjured
mystic conduits that are going to lead
them to particular places to
particularly occasions where they need
to be due to the plan that Adam warlock
has created in order for this to succeed
and that if any of them DV
from this plan that it could very well
lead to the ruin of of the universe as
well as all the superheroes who were
fighting at this point in time what we
also see is that a spell has been cast
that's going to allow these these forces
to breathe within the depths of space
for 60 minutes without any kind of
assistance and this will become very
important because one thing I want you
guys to keep in mind when we get into
the to the coming conflict of the
Infinity Gauntlet is that everything
that's going to take place will take
place over 60 minutes and we will see
when that 60 minutes ends we'll know
when that 60 minutes comes to an end
that's one of the things that Marvel
will tell us is that the 60 minutes is
over and so what he also says here is
that Doctor Strange is going to be in
the background Doctor Strange is going
to going to be monitoring everything and
he's going to be keeping Adam Morlock
aware of what's going on telepathically
from the perspective of every single
superhero at this point we see that
Silver Surfer and and Adam warlock leave
they transition or take off to about a
light year away from where Thanos is
currently at and the Silver Surfer is a
little angry about this the Silver
Surfer is a little irritated about this
that they're simply standing on the
sidelines so they are off to the side
while everybody else is engaging in the
conflict and Silver Surfer tells us that
he is a full power now he is completely
rejuvenated and that his strength would
be a vast asset to the coming battle to
the various superheroes and Adam warlock
says that he is right but that his
strength will most be needed when the
time is right and so what he tells the
Silver Surfer is that he simply just
needs to wait but Silver Surfer much
like a lot of very proud superheroes
doesn't want to but he swallows his
pride here and simply says okay and what
Adam warlock tells us is that Silver
Surfer doesn't truly understand he
doesn't truly comprehend the situation
that Thanos he controls all facets of of
time reality space power the soul and
the mind and that this isn't some kind
of grandiose statement that this is
absolute truth that he's totally
unconvincing that he is completely
omnipotent
that this rhetoric this this statement
isn't just simply rhetoric that this is
this is basically the definition of fan
OHS that he recorded he B controls all
reality he controls all there is he says
that the power of the Allies of these
superheroes is less than nothing to
Thanos that they are defeated before the
battle even begins but that the true
purpose of their attack is to simply be
a diversion that they are sacrificial
lands from here we're going to bring
this comic or bring this video to an end
and in the next video we'll pick up with
the oncoming conflict we'll pick up with
the true conflict as we get into all of
these superheroes fighting against the
forces of fantasy so as we get into part
4 of the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
we're going to be seeing this comic
unfolding from the perspective of eros
and again eros is the brother of Thanos
and heiresses has had has had his
ability to speak removed but he's simply
going to be telling us more or less you
know throughout his thoughts what it is
that's going on here what it is this
taking place what we're also going to be
seeing here is for the most part in
absolute slaughter we're going to be
seeing the earthbound superheroes really
not being able to do anything to oppose
the power of Thanos but the things that
he does to them the way that he chooses
to defeat them I think are very
interesting and if this sort of story
plays out in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
if Marvel is truly going the direction
of the Infinity Gauntlet then I think
for the most part with the exception of
characters like Cyclops and Silver
Surfer being interchanged with other
characters that we'll see this story
unfolding in such a way to where it will
be very intriguing and a very rich sort
of conflict and what we see happening as
the comic opens up is that Earth's
pounds the earthbound superheroes are at
the shrine of mistress death they have
arrived at Thanos location to begin the
conflict but Thanos has used the time
gem to freeze time completely the only
people who were not affected by the
freezing of time his Mephisto mistress
death nebula terr axia who of course was
a creation of Thanos and The Watcher and
eros and what Thanos does here what he
sort of comments on is
the fact that if this is the force that
these superheroes were able to muster
together then he's really not too
concerned he could simply use his
reality gym and just blink them out of
existence entirely and what we see
Mephisto saying is that there are other
individuals with which they know should
concern himself with Nathanael should
concern himself with the Silver Surfer
and with Adam warlock and Thanos remarks
by saying that these two individuals
appear to be the only two individuals
who were intelligent enough to not
challenge his omnipotence and I would
like you guys to pay very close
attention here because again mrs. Thanos
demonstrating a vast amount of arrogance
Thanos while he's normally level-headed
and extremely intelligent ruthless and
cunning seems to have run away with the
ability that he has seems to have run
away with his power and he's more or
less being governed by arrogance and the
belief of absolute power rather than
thinking rationally and simply just any
the conflict to ensure his absolute
victory now what we also see Mephisto
doing here is something very interesting
something very intriguing
Mephisto is Hell stano's to stay his
hand to not kill Adam warlock in the
Silver Surfer in addition what he says
is that this may be a an opportunity in
disguise
Thanos asks Mephisto to continue and
what Mephisto says is that lady death
mistress death just like any other woman
has her heart warmed by courage despite
the fact that her heart is cold she may
find that because Thanos is willing to
be courageous that she is going to she
may find herself more attracted to him
than she previously did and the question
that host has is how do I demonstrate
this courage how can I demonstrate the
fact that I'm courageous when I'm going
against forces that have no ability to
stop me
and what Mephisto says is to not use the
complete power of the gauntlet to more
or less use a portion of the power that
the gauntlet has to allow these
superheroes a chance of victory and if
they are victorious then he will die in
the face of courage and he will earn the
heart of mistress death or he will fight
and win the conflict with everything he
has there by continuing to demonstrate
and winning the heart of mistress death
and that because Thanos has so much
power that this is not something that's
outside of his ability to control this
element this idea immediately rings a
tone with Thanos Thanos latches on to it
and believes that this may very well be
the case and we see eros commenting on
this euro says that this is very strange
this is very weird that for the most
part Mephisto just allowed the
earthbound superheroes the slightest
chance for victory however small however
unlikely it may be they stand more of a
chance now than they ever did before and
so he's more or less trying to figure
out what kind of game if Fisto is
playing here what it is that he's doing
and so what we see Pharaohs doing is
unfreezing time Thanos for the most part
allows the conflict to continue using
own the power Jim now the other thing
here is that eros sees that somebody is
standing over him and when he looks up
he realizes that it's only nebula
now nebula is someone I would like you
to keep in the back of your head because
nebula will become extremely important
in the Infinity Gauntlet storyline but
as the story continues as things move
forward again Thanos says that he's only
going to use his power Jim and that the
power Jim should allow him whatever it
is that he needs to do it will augment
the existing abilities that he has to
the point where he will still be able to
defeat the earthbound superheroes and so
what fantasy does is he snaps his
fingers and time continues from here we
see that Namor the Submariner various
other superheroes who were on a
collision course with destroy and
continue along the path that they were
previously on and various things are
destroyed but what we see as this story
continues is that for the most part this
this belief and the possibility of
victory goes away very very fast and the
reason why is because we see the
Incredible Hulk
using the full power his disposal as
angry as he can possibly get and
attempting to punch Thanos so to me to
assault Thanos but Thanos here appears
to maybe make himself extremely large
make him take on some sort of mass and
he's able to for the most part overpower
the Incredible Hulk or at the very least
push him away but we see that the
actions of the
credible word diversion in order for the
vision to sneak up behind Thanos and
attempt to defeat him but the power that
I the vision has is not enough for
Thanos to be defeated he really doesn't
do much here he simply just kind of
shoots an energy beam if Thanos but
that's pretty much it and again we see
eros continuing to a common here saying
that this strategy was flawlessly
executed that this strategy was
absolutely perfect and that a lesser foe
anyone other than Fanus would have been
defeated here but in the end they're
fighting Thanos and even if nanos were
not using the Infinity Gauntlet he would
still be able to withstand the power
this attack due to the vast power that
Thanos has Thanos goes on to comment and
say that he never would have expected
this kind of an attack this actually
took him by surprise
and again we see eros also commenting
saying that Captain America is leading
the charge which is the reason why a lot
of these attacks are so well coordinated
we see Captain America commenting and
saying to continue on relentlessly
trying to overpower Thanos to continue
trying to do what they can to to defeat
Thanos but again we switch back to eros
here and eros continues to come in and
say that these hopes are vain the
possibility of defeating Thanos is
simply just something that can't be done
and that for the most part he's
awestruck by the fact that in the face
of almost guaranteed victory that the
earthbound superheroes continue at this
point we switch over to Adam warlock in
the Silver Surfer and Adam warlock asked
the Silver Surfer how the conflict is
going and the Silver Surfer says it's
going exactly as expected which of
course means that they simply didn't
expect these superheroes to be very
successful and the Silver Surfer says
that he should be there with them he
should be fighting alongside them and
Adam warlock says this would be utter
folly and the reason why he says this
would be folly is because the Silver
Surfer has a vast and important role
that he is supposed to play here but
Adam warlock won't tell the Silver
Surfer what it is because if the Silver
Surfer knows what it is
Thanos could read the silver surfers
mind and prepare himself for the attack
but when Silver Surfer asks Adam warlock
whether or not this is something that he
should concern himself with the Thanos
may read his mind Adam warlock replies
by saying that this is not
something that Thanos would do now the
whole reason why is something that's not
necessarily explained to us
in this issue but in previous issues and
especially the ongoing series right now
regarding Adam warlock and Thanos in the
Marvel's the Marvel Comics and Adam
warlocks returned to the Marvel Universe
gives us an indication into how it is
their inner minds work which would
actually work in a very warped way they
have this extremely kind of screwed up
perspective on the universe but we
switch back to the conflict with Thanos
who is now fighting against name of the
Submariner and she-hulk
and what we see is that Thanos
physically punches both of them he
physically touches both of them and when
he does some kind of growth begins to
develop on them and the growth begins to
spread extremely fast and what this is
is something that we're not explicitly
told they simply just seem to be covered
in dirt or seem to be converting into
dirt indicating to us that maybe Thanos
is either using the power gym to
possibly hyperjump their evolution or is
using the power gym to work them into
something else but whatever it is it
happens to take place here the name of
the Submariner and she-hulk are
effectively out of commission they're no
longer able to fight alongside the other
superheroes and this again is what we
see being continued on with this
discussion with eros eros says that the
the campaign that's going on here the
conflict that's going on here the way
that things are being fought is
Stannis's forte this is Thanos at his
absolute peak at his absolute best he is
really in full form here and the reason
why is because Thanos always does best
when he's put into a circumstance where
he has he uses intellect in conjunction
with his power and this is what we see
Thea knows doing is more or less
countering the attacks of various
superheroes but it's doing it in such a
way to where he has to think out what it
is that they're going to do from here we
see Thor and Doctor Doom continuing an
attack on Thanos and again Thor simply
just throws his hammer Eric Masterson
throws his hammer into Thor and to
Thanos and Thanos seems to be knocked
down here at this point Doctor Doom goes
to make a grab for the gauntlet and
again this was the entire intention of
Doctor Doom coming along here Doctor
Doom didn't really care about the
survival of the
verse only and so far that he survived
his main goal here was to grab the
Infinity Gauntlet was to attain absolute
power but what we see as as Doctor Doom
attempts to grab the gauntlet is that
Thanos is able to throw him off
Thanos is able to to shoot him to the
other side of the shrine as a
consequence of dr. doom trying to grab
his gauntlet at this point we switched
to Thor - Eric Masterson who was
continuing to attempt to combat Thanos
but for the most part he's just not very
effective here as Eric Masterson throws
the hammer of Thor towards Thanos Thanos
creates a portal and the portal sends
the hammer somewhere else now we're not
exactly sure where it sends it at the
moment but Eric Masterson begins to
panic and the reason why here is because
if he does not retain the hammer within
60 seconds you'll turn back into his
normal mortal form he'll lose the form
of Thor and so we see him
saying that every moment has to be
counted here that he has to do
everything he can to to punch Thanos but
as this conflict continues as his
assault on Thanos continues we see the
Thanos is slightly taken aback as Eros
comments but in the end it doesn't
really matter that fan OHS is easily
able to overpower Thor and what he says
is that this is a massive blow to the
morale of the superheroes because this
was a very high-stakes card game and
that Thor due to his vast power and the
power that he has while wielding the
hammer was their ace in the hole but
because of the fact that Eric Masterson
is so easily defeated by Thanos it
really shines a light on how little of a
chance the earthbound superheroes have
against fighting Thanos at this point we
switch to fire Lord and Fire Lord is
beginning his assault on Thea ghin this
is simply just a distraction and the
distraction will for the most part cost
the life of a Fire Lord but in return
we'll see that Wolverine is able to jump
into action to attempt to destroy Thanos
to attempt to kill thanos using his
adamantium claws but again this doesn't
really matter that much this is just
another instance of Thanos using his
power and what Thanos does
more or less warp the mind or work the
body of a wolf's brain warp his
adamantium skeleton and what he does
here is he changes the the metal the
adamantium in his body into a rubbery
material and so Wolverines bones are now
rubber his body is just simply not able
to move he has no real lung solid form
and so Wolverine now is completely out
of commission at this point we switch
over to dr. doom who is attempting to
again assault Thanos once more he is
starting his attack and Thanos some
comments by asking dr. doom if he's
attempting to take another shot at
stealing his Infinity Gauntlet and dr.
doom says that only death will stay his
hand that only death will keep him from
attempting to usurp Thanos as power and
that simply says that can be arranged at
this point we switch over to to Adam
warlock and the Silver Surfer and
eternity has made his presence known to
Adam warlock saying that Libra Restless
now the cosmic entities are ready to get
involved in a conflict but Adam warlock
simply sends him off and tells him that
if he stays the Thanos will sense his
presence and then also be aware of the
next step of the conflict we also see
that Adam warlock tells the Silver
Surfer that to him the Eternity is no
more of a piece on the chessboard than
the other superheroes who were fighting
and Silver Surfer gets angry hear that
Adam warlock views this conflict as
nothing more than a game but what Adam
warlock says is that if he view this is
anything other than a game then he
wouldn't be able to go on just because
the the overall pressure the
consequences of what it would mean to
fail would overwhelm him at this point
we switch back to Thanos
as he's fighting out the Scarlet Witch
and Cyclops then again we see eros
continuing to comment here and arrow
says that for the most part the power of
Cyclops and the Scarlet Witch are again
really nothing compared to the power
that Thanos has and the Thanos weighing
the options of the power that these
individuals possess chooses to go after
the Scarlet Witch first and he uses his
powers to more or less override the
ability that the Scarlet Witch has to
overcharge her powers and more or less I
guess put her out of commission
at this point he switches over to to
Cyclops and Cyclops continuing he uses
optic beams on Thanos that blasts him
with a vast amount of power and then
suddenly stops and because he suddenly
stops Thanos is thrown off guard
eros comments that this is a masterful
move and that the basis of this was to
throw Thanos off guard so that Tony
Stark Iron Man could swoop in and deal a
energy shot to Thanos
but again the power that that Iron Man
has here is just not enough to really do
anything against Thanos it's just not
enough to to do any real damage to
Thanos even while he's simply just using
the power gym and so what we see is that
Tarak SIA jumps into the fray and Tarak
SIA does what she can to physically
defeat Iron Man and we see that Cyclops
goes back on the offensive and begins
blasting Thanos with his optic beans but
then Thanos he uses his power it appears
as though he may be cheating a little
bit and using the reality gym but he
creates a glass box around the head of
Cyclops and this does two things the
first thing that it does is of course it
cuts off his optic beams but the other
thing it does it's cut off the oxygen to
him we see Captain America running to
his side as the vision attempts to come
up behind Thanos and sneak attack him
but for the most part Thanos as it's
explained to us by eros never falls for
the same trick twice and so for the most
part what we see happening here is that
Thanos is more or less punching a hole
in envision and Captain America in the
background is trying to destroy the
glass box over the head of Cyclops but
what we see is that as vision is
destroyed Thor who was previously
knocked out into space by Thanos is
trying to make his way back to the
shrine but as he gets back the the the
power wears off the effect of Thor wears
off and so he switches back to his
mortal form as Eric Masterson and what
we realize here as again is explained to
us by eros is that the spell that was
used by Doctor Strange to make sure that
these characters can breathe in space
for 5060 minutes appears to only apply
I to Thor as he's wielding his hammer
and not to the mortal form of Eric
Masterson and so Eric Masterson begins
to suffocate at this point we switch
back to Captain America and Captain
America tells us that Cyclops is dead
it's like Cyclops had suffocated inside
of the glass box and Thanos sort of
lashed this off he pokes fun at Captain
America by saying this is an emotional
outburst and it's something that we he
would not have expected from the
emotional or from the legendary Captain
America but what we also see taking
place here is that cloak is sneaking up
behind Thanos and an attempt to ensnare
him and trap him in the Dark Dimension
but we see that as cloak wraps his uh
his cape around Thanos that initially it
seems as though he might be able to keep
Thanos can find that Thanos may for the
most part be defeated and trapped inside
the the dark area that that cloak traps
his foes in but as we see vanos is not
contained that Thanos breaks out of the
Dark Dimension and appears to destroy
cloak in the process at this point
Thanos declares that he cannot be in
prison that supremacy cannot be
suppressed in prison and that his
Definity is absolute at this point we
see that again the superheroes begin to
go on the offensive against against
Thanos and his forces we see that Terr
Axia is able to rip the head off of Tony
Stark and that Drax a destroyer
attempts to defeat Thanos once more and
again Thanos is displaying a vast amount
of bravado here a vast amount of
arrogance but he also appears to be
losing his mind entirely as the power
begins to continue to go to his head and
so what we see is that arrows comments
euros said simply says that everybody
seems to know what's going on here
everybody seems to recognize the
insanity that Thanos is displaying here
that for the most part he is so far
removed from the Thanos who was peering
into the infinity well and tracking down
the infinity gems that in each chance
that he possibly had of gaining the in
the affection of mistress death is for
the most part entirely gone but eros
also comments and says that the only
person who doesn't really seem to care
about what's going on here with Ana
is nebula and again nebula as she's
described to us by eros is more or less
just kind of a a caricature more or less
a husk of what used to be a person she's
simply just walking this line between
life and death and euros goes as far as
to say that she would be better off dead
from here we switched to Thor and Erik
Masterson as he is continuing to try to
pull the hammer towards himself with a
hammer again is simply just being
teleported to a different location but
then we see the hammer lands in front of
him and when it does when he dies as
he's a momentarily approaching death he
picks up the hammer and has granted the
power of Thor again at this point we see
that Thanos opens up a time portal and
he sucks in Drax the destroyer and Fire
Lord and they're sent back into the
earth prehistoric period but what we
also see is that sure axia is saying
that she's managed to dispatch iron man
that she has killed Tony Stark more or
less as she's ripped a head off of his
of his shield or I'm sorry of his suit
we see that uh that that vana says that
he loves a woman who shares his same
values who for the most part is a
reflection of him and it almost seems as
though he's getting ready to say that
she's a person he may come to love but
before he can speak we see that Spider
Man shoots webbing in the face of Thanos
which again is something a little bit
funny here a little bit of entertainment
to the dark nature of this story so far
and of course spider-man swings in and
we also see quasar as well as Thor
arriving to attempt to defeat the forces
of Thanos including Terr axia but for
the most part again this really isn't
much of a conflict to Axia is able to
subdue spider-man for the most part and
Thor Eric Masterson continues pummeling
away at fan oohs he says that Thanos
wiping out half the life from the
universe is probably the worst act he
thinks he could have committed and that
this is simply not something that can be
allowed to pass that Thor that Eric
Masterson is going to use all of his
power to try to kill thanos even if it
means killing himself in the process but
what we see is that Thanos he uses his
Infinity Gauntlet to Thurn to turn Thor
into glass into a solid piece of glass
and so again we see this comic being
made here that finally people are
starting to understand the realization
of the truth that for the most part all
is lost that Thanos using the power of
the Infinity Gauntlet could kill and
eliminate all the forces of the
earthbound superheroes in any one of a
thousand ways and so for the most part
this battle again was over before it
even started at this point we see Nova
arrive and as Richard Ryder flies in he
simply tells Thanos that this is not
going to happen that no one is going to
destroy Thor as long as he is around but
then Thanos comments by saying Square
not round squares and cubes and he
simply converts her I guess Rima T
realises Nova into a series of
children's blocks again demonstrating to
us the absolute power that Thanos
possesses here at this point we see
Thanos destroy the crystal form of Thor
and then we see quasar stepping into the
fray and for the most part quasar was a
character that we wouldn't necessarily
have looked at as somebody that could
single-handedly destroy Thanos but given
the power the extreme energies that he's
able to manipulate using the the quantum
bands that at the very least he would be
able to put up some kind of a fight but
Thanos doesn't really consider quasar to
be anyone of any real significance he
simply looks at quasar and refers to
quasar as the replacement for the late
captain marvel and quasar goes as far as
to say that the quantum bands that he
wields will be the downfall of Thanos
but almost immediately his quantum bands
are destroyed by Thanos and quasars for
the most part rendered entirely useless
Thanos then uses his power to destroy
quasar entirely to completely
disintegrate his body and so now what we
see is that for the most part all these
superheroes are totally out of
commission Wolverines entire skeleton is
made of a spongy material the vision has
been destroyed by having a circuitry
ripped out by Thanos Cyclops has
suffocated spider-man is unconscious and
Tony Stark has had his head ripped off
and so this again is more or less
Stannis demonstrating to us
that all hope is lost here that there
really isn't an instance where anybody
can do anything but what we see is that
Captain America for the most part
appears to be the last man standing and
Captain America simply tells Thanos that
it's not over until it's over that until
all of the earthbound heroes are dead
until there's no one left to fight
Thanos that there will always be
somebody to pick up the mantle and never
Captain America he had always lived by
the fact that for him good will always
triumph that you have to fight until the
end even if the end means you're certain
death but what we also see here is Adam
warlock telling the Silver Surfer to
prepare himself to get ready and so we
see that Captain America begins to to
advance on to Thanos and to more-or-less
despite the fact that he's vastly out
powered by Thanos to refuse to accept
defeat to more or less tell Thanos that
he's going to do everything he can to
attempt to stop him and what what uh
what Captain America says here again is
that as long as one man stands Thanos
we'll never be able to claim victory but
Pharaoh says that these are notable
noble sentiments that these are noble
sentiments from person who's about to be
killed we see that a Silver Surfer says
that Thanos is going to kill Captain
America and so he has to intervene but
Adam warlock says to wait Captain
America replies to Thanos by saying that
he's always held these sentiments that
he's always believed that one man can
make the difference between absolute
defeat and absolute victory and so these
words these this creed that he has is a
Creed worth dying for and Thanos simply
replies by saying then he shall die for
these words and he simply destroys his
his shield by smacking it at this point
we see that as he's getting ready to
deal the killing blow to Captain America
we see that that Adam warlock yells at
Silver Surfer to run to move as fast as
he can and so we see Silver Surfer using
all of his energy to travel as fast as
he possibly can across the cosmos to
where Thanos is at and in almost the
blink of an eye a Silver Surfer has
arrived at his location and what we see
is that the goal of Silver Surfer here
is to snatch the Infinity Gauntlet
the hand of Thanos as he's getting ready
to kill Captain America but at the very
last second we see that Thanos realizes
what it is that the Silver Surfer is
trying to do and is able to keep his
Infinity Gauntlet from being stolen at
this point Thanos begins to come to he
begins to regain his senses regain his
sanity and he realizes that he's been a
fool here that he has allowed the words
of Mephisto to more or less override his
logic override his reason and so he more
or less reverts back to the old fairness
that we knew where he would go into
conflict with with an inset with a I
guess a logic with a solid mindset in
terms of how best to defeat his
opponents and so what he says is that he
almost lost it all due to his arrogance
due to his insanity he almost lost the
Infinity Gauntlet and so he wills
himself back to full power he wills
himself back to being able to manipulate
all of the power that the Infinity
Gauntlet possesses and so the first
thing we see him do is say that he wills
himself to clear the entire battlefield
of everything that's there to clear the
entire battlefield of all the dead
bodies and all the destruction because
what's coming is going to be a far
greater struggle than what he's just
been through Adam warlock begins to
comment and say that they try to do it
the easy way and they failed and so now
the conflict is coming that he tried to
avoid the conflict is coming that he
didn't want to have because a conflict
that the universe may not survive and so
because on eternity and the rest of the
cosmic entities so it's finally here
after a week and a half of waiting which
you guys have been so patient for we're
finally getting back into the Infinity
Gauntlet series and we're picking up
with issue number five but in order to
refresh you guys in order to make make
sure that you guys recall where it was
that we left off we're gonna touch back
on issue number four and what we had
seen with issue number four words that
the earthbound superheroes had engaged
convinence and conflict and as we had
seen famous was able to make quick work
of the earthbound superheroes and this
was for a singular purpose it was
designed to be a diversion as Adam
warlock had explained it to us there was
no real expectation that the earthbound
superheroes would
seed the purpose of them was to distract
Thanos away from Adam warlock actual
plan when the plan that Adam warlock had
was to have the Silver Surfer intervene
at the most opportune moment whereby he
would snatch the gauntlet off the hand
of Thanos
but as we had seen vanos was able to
keep this from happening at the very
last second and retained the Infinity
Gauntlet for himself and so we saw Adam
warlock bringing in the second group of
forces we saw him introducing the cosmic
entities and as we see with issue number
five as it begins to open up is that
Thanos is confronting the the cosmic
entities and again I'd like you to
notice the amount of arrogance that
Thanos is displaying here what he's
telling the the cosmic entities is that
the power he possesses is beyond
anything they could understand and again
this is Thanos being very arrogant the
first reason why he's so arrogant here
the reason why it seems that he's so so
confident is because he possesses all
this power but the other reason here is
because he does not necessarily have the
same wisdom that a lot of these cosmic
entities have because they've been in
existence since the dawn of existence in
this reality because their
manifestations various represented
representations of reality for example
eternity being the very representation
of the essence of everything within the
cosmos the ongoings of reality itself of
course has existed since the dawn of
reality so we've seen countless
civilizations and countless organisms
come into existence and then die and so
forth Ana's to appear and to say he
knows more than they do is quite an
arrogant thing to say what we also see
is that Mephisto is being a little
manipulative here and again we'll see
you later on that Mephisto has his own
Mecca nations in terms of his
involvement with Thanos but we see that
time if Vista was more or less poking
fun at eros he's talking to eros about
how Thanos would this absolute power is
most likely going to unleash it in its
full force in order to either
demonstrate his power to the cosmic
entities or it's going to be necessary
for him to defeat the cosmic entities
but because such a vast amount of power
is going to be released in such a way
that most likely it will result in the
destruction of eros now he says that
because then
can manipulate the very fabric of
reality most likely he will destroy
anything he cares about I'm sorry I
restore anything he cares about that had
been destroyed and that this may very
well in kill include eros but he says
that if eros has brought back that most
likely he will be brought back in the
same form as a nebula more or less a
husk of what used to be a sentient being
and so free eros this is horrifying
euros is absolutely distraught at the
idea of coming back and kind of walking
this line between life and death
not necessarily being considered alive
but not being allowed to die and so what
we see as the conflict begins to unfold
as things begin to progress is that
Thanos unleashes this power that he has
and the way it's done here it seems to
be just absolute power absolute raw
ability and The Watcher explains to us
and telling us that this is the initial
clash this is the initial conflict that
the cosmic entities have with Thanos and
what we'll see as the story progresses
is that the cosmic entities will each
take turns trying to defeat Thanos using
the powers that are relevant to them and
what The Watcher tells us here is that
he's afraid that this may very well
herald the end of the universe this may
bring everything to an end just because
of the sheer amount of power that's
going to be displayed but as we see as
things begin to take their toll as the
damage begins to become apparent that
the entire shrine that Thanos had made
towards mistress death had been
destroyed as well as according to The
Watcher various solar systems and
galaxies within the direct I guess the
immediate area of where Thanos is
unleashing his power from we then at
this point switched to eros then eros
was absolutely certain he was going to
be killed he was absolutely sure he was
going to die but what was very
surprising to eros was not only the fact
that he was very much alive but the fact
that he was being saved or being kept
alive by mistress death herself
alongside nebula and so what arrow
speculates here is that the hatred that
mistress death has for Thanos is quite
possibly something none of them can
understand just because she's going to
the lengths of saving the individuals
which stano's to test the most and so
again this may simply just be an
instance of her saying as she
absolutely despises Thanos at this point
we switched to Adam warlock in the
silver surfer and Adam warlock comments
that is absolute luck that they survive
that for whatever reason they somehow
made it out of here but almost
immediately after the the initial
explosion and they're sort of calming
down due to the fact that they've
managed to survive this there's some
kind of strange thing emanating around
them and what Adam warlock tells the
Silver Surfer is that this is an
interdimensional distortion cascade now
what this means exactly is not something
that's explained to us this moment but
what we see as the story continues is
that Adam warlock says that they need to
get out of here as soon as they can
because if they get sucked into it they
may not survive they may be sent to
another dimension they may be eradicated
entirely in addition this
interdimensional distortion cascade is
explained to us further once it reaches
the planet Earth and what this seems to
be is perhaps a weakening or a a love
and maybe dissolving of the barriers
between dimensions between realities and
this seems to become apparent for a
couple reasons the first is that at this
point again the earth has been moved or
has been sort of bumped out of its orbit
from the Sun and so the earth is
becoming colder and colder but we see
that the portal between the negative
zone where Annihilus resides and the
planet earth seems to have at the very
least been weakened or maybe torn apart
entirely and so Annihilus is able to
enter the dimension of the earth-616
universe in the planet earth from the
negative zone from here we see a
nihilist continuing to implement his
schemes with a cosmic control rod and
his force is saying that they are for
the most part going to conquer the
planet Earth at this point we switch
back to Thanos and what we see pharaohs
doing is using his Infinity Gauntlet to
demonstrate his absolute power to
demonstrate his ability and as The
Watcher described it to us this is
something to behold that the heavens
themselves tremble now again the
important thing to keep in mind here is
that despite the fact that Thanos is
able to wield all of this power that it
is confined to the earth-616 universe
the Thanos is not affecting any other
universes that may exist or that do
exist around him what we also see is
that the Celestials are the first
one's to step into the conflict towards
Thanos and the Celestials use various
planets as a means to attempt to topple
Thanos or attempt to somehow destroy him
or incapacitate him and The Watcher says
that these planets are inhabited
although it may very well be that at
this point because they're so far
removed from the warmth of the Sun that
most likely would have kept the
inhabitants alive that they may very
well be dead that it's not relevant that
the goings on of these these organisms
these celestial beings cannot be a
consideration in this conflict that they
have to more or less be sacrificed in
order for the greater good to come out
but we see that again the analyst is
able to use the power of the Infinity
Gauntlet to easily not only destroy
these these planets the forces that the
Celestials are trying to use to defeat
Thanos but to defeat the Celestials
entirely now it's important to remember
that ups isn't actually killing the
Celestials he's more or less simply just
sort of defeating them here the next
group up is or I guess the next
individual up is Chronos and again
Chronos is able to manipulate the very
fabric of time and this is what he
attempts to do with Thanos he attempts
to maybe somehow bury Thanos within the
depths of time as The Watcher explains
it to us or to maybe send him to a place
in time where he doesn't know where he
is or doesn't know how to get back but
again because Thanos is able to
manipulate all facets of time he
immediately travels back to the present
and he more or less is able to defeat
Kronos he's more or less able to do
whatever it is that he has to do in
order to incapacitate Chronos at this
point we jumped a master order and Lord
chaos and what we see master order and
word chaos during here is using their
respective powers using the respective
dichotomies I guess in an attempt to
sort of dichotomize Thanos in an attempt
to I guess maybe strip away the order
that makes him who he is the very
fundamental fabric of his existence by
separating the element of him that is I
guess orderly and the element of him
that is absolutely chaotic now what
would actually happen in this whether or
not he was simply just split into two
separate beings or he would more or less
be a representation of what would happen
if matter met antimatter and he would
simply just cease to exist
there's something that we don't know
because what we see as the Thanos is
very easily able to defeat master order
in Lord chaos he's able to as The
Watcher explains it retain his own
individuality he's able to maintain what
it is that makes him a complete being
from here we switched to the stranger to
to Galactus and to the the
representation I guess of the new form
of Aeon and what we see here is that
these individuals attempt to use their
absolute power they attempt to use all
the power that's available to them in an
attempt to more or less override or to
overthrow the power of Fano stood simply
just I guess encompass him with so much
power that there really isn't anything
he can do to stop them but again we see
Fano simply just using the power of the
Infinity Gauntlet to easily defeat them
and what you're seeing here is this kind
of pattern you're seeing the Thanos is
able to more or less just use the
Infinity Gauntlet to simply wipe away
everything that everybody is to simply
just eliminate them almost entirely now
again he's not killing them he's simply
just incapacitating them or
demonstrating to them there's nothing
they can really do at this point we
switch to Thanos sort of having this
debate between himself he's arguing with
himself here he's saying that on one
side that somehow he may have lost his
mind here that these individuals are his
friends they're his heavenly brothers as
he describes them but on the other side
he's arguing with himself he's saying
that they deserve what's taking place
here they deserve the punishment that
he's giving them and that he's going to
kill them all but then we see the Thanos
begins to realize what it is as taking
place he realizes that this is not
necessarily an actual argument that he's
having with himself that his emotions
his perspectives are being manipulated
and that these perspectives are being
manipulated by mistress love and sire
hate and again these are the opposing
forces of love and hate within the
universe and the house is able to banish
them he's able to defeat them in the
same way that he was able to defeat the
other cosmic entities but then we see
the Mephisto makes his mecca nations
known Mephisto
thanos with hell's fire and when he does
he leaps at Thanos and attempts to
remove his Infinity Gauntlet and Thanos
is actually a little surprised by this
he's a little shocked to see that
Mephisto
is attempting to manipulate him now
whether or not this is because Thanos is
simply just never really taken the time
to read the mind of Mephisto or because
Mephisto was somehow able to shield his
mind from Thanos it's something that we
don't know but given the fact that
Thanos has the mind gym and has absolute
power over the minds of others were most
likely led to believe the pharaohs had
simply just not questioned the the
allegiance of Mephisto and again this is
most likely pointing to the arrogance
that Thanos had that anyone is going to
side with him side with him because they
realize how powerful elite he is and it
would be foolish for them to do anything
otherwise from here we see the fan oasiz
again able to easily overpower Mephisto
and is in the process or I guess is
preparing to kill Mephisto for his
actions but before he can actually kill
Mephisto we see that the two of them are
separated by the actions of a third
party and what we see is that mistress
death has intervened on behalf of
Mephisto and saved his life by more or
less putting pushing Thanos out of the
way and Thanos feels betrayed here he
feels angry here because for him this is
the ultimate step that mistress death
has taken to demonstrate that not only
has he not gained her affections but
that there's nothing he can really do
here in this circumstance as it appears
to please her Thanos says that he
offered her the universe that he did
everything he could to make her happy
but she simply just couldn't accept it
at this point we see the cosmic entities
using their power alongside Mephisto and
mistress death to I guess intervene
while he's distracted and to blast them
with or bless him with the I guess all
of their combined powers but again
Thanos recognizes what it is is taking
place here and immediately overpowers
all of them and when he does he
imprisons them he places them in some
kind of a cosmic stasis now most likely
as is displayed here or at least as we
can see they may simply just be
temporarily
I guess paralyzed or temporarily
imprisoned
they're not making any effort to escape
their bonds they're not making any
effort to escape their struggle and so
it seems as though that for the most
part he's imprisoned and frozen them so
whether or not they actually know what's
going on here is something that we don't
really know anything about where
somebody just aware that they're frozen
in place and so what Fano says is that
this is the best way for things to
function at the moment that he simply
just needs time to focus he needs time
to be unburdened
with the emotions of his feelings of
betrayal by mistress death and to simply
take the time and the logic to decide
what his next step will be at this point
we see that Adam warlock and the Silver
Surfer don't necessarily go as far as to
say that all time or I guess all hope
may be lost but they're actually going
through the process of trying to find
survivors because again some of these
superheroes are still left alive and so
what they say is that among the wreckage
they need to find help but among the
planets that have been destroyed here
are some or I guess at least one planet
that the Silver Surfer recognizes and
the Silver Surfer says that he visited
this planet before whether or not it was
something he had done on behalf of
Thanos or something he was just curious
about saying isn't explained to us but
he says they have to search for these
individuals they have to search for
these these survivors among the wreckage
Adam warlock initially advises against
it but the Silver Surfer says that this
is an instance where bahi is not going
to heed the advice of Adam warlock that
the desire to protect those that are
unable to save themselves as a result of
the conflict overrides the fact that
they needed to sort of recap their
forces here but what we see as Adam
warlock and the Silver Surfer approach
this planet is that there is no one left
then all these individuals are dead all
these these beings that existed on this
planet are completely ended or I guess
completely destroyed from here we see
that at the Silver Surfer actually takes
this quite hard the Silver Surfer as is
explained by Adam warlock is an
individual despite his vast powers that
functions in the same capacity for the
most part as other sentient beings in
that he feels love he feels hate he
feels remorse and this is a very
overwhelming experience for the Silver
Surfer to know that the entire
inhabitants of this planet
have been destroyed in the midst of all
this chaos and so the Silver Surfer says
this needs to end Adam warlock agrees
here Adam warlock says that Thanos is
Annihilus and that in order for this
conflict to come to an end that he has
to be defeated entirely otherwise he
will eliminate all life in the universe
not necessarily because he's looking to
appease mistress death anymore but
because he is in effect a heartbroken
being and will lash out at virtually
everybody from this point we see that
eternity has now joined the fray and
eternity is as we know the most powerful
of the cosmic entities and so this
conflict between Thanos and eternity
will for the most part tell us exactly
who it is that it's more powerful here
whether or not if stano's using his
Infinity Gauntlet or eternity using the
vast power of the very fabric of the
earth-616 universe within itself as a
means to combat Thanos what we see
Pharaoh saying here is that the prize
that awaits him with defeating eternity
is something he has struggled for the
absolute authority of power within the
universe is something he has strived for
in this as he explains to us is the
actual result of this plan this is
really what he was looking for when he
went about the process of capturing the
infinity gems and what we see is that
eternity simply tells Thanos to prepare
himself to defend himself but before we
actually see what takes place between
the two of them there's some kind of an
explosion or some kind of conflict and
all we see is Oh as a bright light with
Adam warlock and Silver Surfer saying
that this that this can't be the end
this can't be the end of the universe
but this conflict has to somehow come to
an end entirely from here we see the
Silver Surfer and Adam warlock more or
less surprised by what it is that's
going on and Adam warlock says that the
end of this battle has more or less
already been decided
Adam warlock here I'm sorry Silver
Surfer asks how it is that Adam warlock
knows this and Adam warlock says that
he's linked to the infinity gems in ways
that even he doesn't understand and so
the question that's asked here by the
Silver Surfer is who's come out on top
here is it eternity or is it Thanos with
the Infinity Gauntlet what he says is
that the person who loses is the person
who is true
and defeat subconsciously who has
already simply just allowed himself to
lose and so what we see that a Morlock
more or less saying is that the
successor here is most likely Thanos and
the reason why is because the Eternity
recognized the fact that they honest
probably has more power than he does but
that eternity is not fighting logically
he's not fighting reasonably he's
fighting out of anger he's fighting out
of rage he's allowing his emotions to
get the better of him and when a person
fights in an emotional state they're not
thinking rationally and by virtue they
can't be intelligent at this point we
see Adam warlock telling dr. strange
that they need to be retrieved and so
Doctor Strange teleports them back to
the planet Earth what we see again kind
of going on here is this explanation of
what all's taken place that the cosmic
entities have been imprinted imprisoned
but then we get I guess a little further
expansion by saying here that causes I
guess the Eternity is one of the cosmic
entities that has now been imprisoned
indicating to us that Thanos has in fact
come out on top
that Thanos has been able to use his
power to defeat eternity and so from
here we see that for the most part
Thanos doesn't necessarily appear to be
dead he simply appears to be unconscious
and taraji is trying to speak with him
she's trying to awaken him from her from
his state and she she asked him to
simply just speak to say something to do
something to indicate that he's alive
but what we see is that Thanos appears
in the I guess the cosmic entity form of
eternity indicating to us that Thanos
has usurped eternity as the absolute
authority within the Marvel earth-616
universe from here we're gonna bring the
first part of video number five I guess
an infinity table number five to an end
and then pick up in the next video when
we see this sort of panic taking place
and we see that the defeat of Thanos
comes from what we would consider to be
the most unlikely person the one person
that none of us had really considered to
be a threat at this particular point
so as we pick up with the second half of
Infinity Gauntlet issue number five
we're actually gonna see things move at
a crew at a pretty quick pace in
addition we're going to see the
circumstances begin to flip on Thanos
and again this is all tied to Thanos as
arrogance because what we see taking
place here is that The Watcher is
informing us that Thanos has usurped the
role of eternity and so within the
earth-616 universe Thanos reign supreme
Thanos has absolute power and Thanos
comments on this Thanos responds tutor
Axia when when she asked him about his
body and he says it's no longer needed
that he's rid himself of something as
bases flesh and that he's rid himself of
all vulnerable 'ti and The Watcher
comments The Watcher says that because
Thanos has absolute power within this
universe that Thanos can virtually
change anything he wants to that the
earth-616 universe is subject to his
every whim and that this may very well
lead to the destruction of the universe
or even if it doesn't it may lead to the
universe being I guess it revocable
changed but what we see taking place
here is that again
Thanos as arrogance has gotten the best
of him that infant knows failing to more
or less keep things in check that he has
to come to the fact that there are
individuals out there despite the fact
that they're only mortal that do have
the ability to defeat him and the reason
for this is because while Thanos has
swept up in the idea of having absolute
power he fails to realize that nebula
has her own thoughts and her own
emotions that nebula despite the fact
that she's somewhat of a husk has this
understanding that Thanos wielding
absolute power with the Infinity
Gauntlet could simply just be seized
from him if she chose to do so and
that's what she does what we see is that
almost immediately after Thanos serves
the role of eternity and while everybody
else is distracted nebula takes the
chance to take the Infinity Gauntlet
from Thanos and when she does vanos
reverts back to his normal form he loses
this absolute power to rack SIA
initially tries to intervene here she
tries to stop nebula but she's not able
to and so what we see is that nebula
using the Infinity Gauntlet
restores herself back to her previous
form back to the point in which she is a
normal healthy being and so she's sort
of taunts Thanos here she tells Thanos
that the mantle of absolute power rests
on new shoulders that she is in fact the
one that wields absolute power and what
she tells Thanos is that of all the
things that she could do with the
Infinity Gauntlet the one thing she
wants to do most at this moment is to
get revenge on Thanos and so what she
does is she banishes Thanos and Tarak
SIA into deep space from here we
transitioned back to Adam warlock the
Silver Surfer and Doctor Strange and the
residents of dr. strange and Adam
warlock immediately realizes that the
Infinity Gauntlet has changed hands that
Thanos is no longer in possession of it
and so what he says here is that things
have gone from bad to worse now why this
has happened is something that we don't
we won't fully understand for the next a
little bit but Adam warlock simply gives
us a brief explanation by saying that
nebula as a result of her experience
walking the line between life and death
in addition to the past experiences she
has had has left her in a state of total
derangement and pain and anguish and so
as a result she could very well just
destroy the universe without really
intending to and so what we see is Adam
warlock telling dr. strange that they
need his his mystic powers from here we
transitioned back to 2002 Axia and what
we see fan was doing here is be I guess
lamenting in a way is more or less
remorse over the fact that Tarak SIA has
died and the reason why is because while
Thanos had created Sir Axia using the
power of the Infinity Gauntlet he had
not created her in a way to where she
could survive deep space and so she's
not able to survive she has in fact died
as a result of her inability to resume
ibly breathe outside of the protection
of the shrine he had created for
mistress death and so Thanos feels left
alone he feels like he's the only one
left and for the most part he's
beginning to think about this he's
beginning to draw on the experience of
losing an individual that he held most
dearly when a portal opens beneath him
and the gravity on the other side
the portal pulls him through once Thanos
gets through the portal what we see is
that he's joined joining Adam warlock
the Silver Surfer and Doctor Strange
again within the residence of Doctor
Strange and the immediate reaction of
the Silver Surfer is to attack Thanos
and again the reason why here is because
the Silver Surfer despite the fact that
he had led Galactus to various planets
had always led Galactus to uninhabited
planets after the silver surfers
encounter with the Fantastic Four and so
he view stano's as a person beyond any
sort of a remorse a person beyond any
ability to I guess maybe make up for
Argus to atone for his actions and so he
feels as though the only thing that can
be done here is to destroy Thanos but
how it also go as far as to say that
there's a little bit of revenge here -
in the sense that Thanos had killed
helpless beings now initially Doctor
Strange tries to intervene but Adam
warlock tells him to stay back because
the power between the Silver Surfer and
Thanos is more than Adam warlock or
Doctor Strange can deal with and so Adam
warlock tells Doctor Strange to a summon
help Doctor Strange says he's ahead of
Adam warlock here and what we see is
that Doctor Strange opens a portal and
when he does he retrieves the only five
superheroes that had survived the
encounter with Thanos these superheroes
being Erik Masterson as Thor The
Incredible Hulk Fire Lord
Doctor Doom and Drax the destroyer and
when they arrive they're able to pull
that us and the Silver Surfer of heart
Adam warlock begins to comment and say
that the whole reason why Thanos is here
is to help them save the universe from
destruction and what Thanos does is he
gives us an explanation as to why it is
the Infinity Gauntlet is in such
dangerous hands into the possession of
nebula what Thanos tells us here is that
it's not enough to simply just wield the
Infinity Gauntlet that the Infinity
Gauntlet has an intense Toller takes an
intense toll on the mind of the person
who wields it and that Thanos by virtue
of his intellect and his past
experiences in addition to the fact that
he is a hybrid of of I guess deviant and
eternal
of sorts is it was able to manipulate
the infinity Gong in such a way to where
he could control it more or less but
that nebula doesn't have this nebula
does not have the intellect to withstand
the overwhelming sensations that the
Infinity Gauntlet brings to her she
doesn't have the the mental fortitude to
withstand the sudden rush of the
recognition of all life in the universe
the sudden rush of the knowledge of
knowing that everything is within her
control and so because of this her mind
as fragile as it is may very well crack
and when it does she may subconsciously
destroy the universe and everybody in it
and so what we see is that we transition
back to Adam warlock and we see Adam
warlock more or less asking everybody if
they agree to the plan that he's created
now at the moment we don't know what
this plan is and we would actually won't
find out what it is until Infinity
Gauntlet
issue number six and when Adam warlock
and Thanos or alone Adam warlock I guess
I Thanos asked Adam warlock what it is
that he wants and Adam warlock says that
they need Thanos help that is not simply
as though Thanos can or cannot choose
that day the plan cannot go through if
Thanos doesn't agree to assist them and
Thanos asks why he says what would
happen if he chose not to to intervene
if he chose not to fight on behalf of of
Adam warlock and the other superheroes
and the question is what does he benefit
from or what benefit does he gain if he
chooses to fight on their behalf Adam
warlock replies by saying that he'll
give fanouts the truth and Thanos asks
what truth he's talking about and Adam
warlock says it is to the truth within
fanos and this is a very intriguing
conversation here because what Adam
warlock tells us is that while he was
within the soul Jim and while Thanos
wielded the soul Jim where as long as it
was in his possession that Adam warlock
had a very unique viewpoint of Thanos
his inner soul he was able to in fact
look within Thanos himself and the one
thing that he was able to understand
here is that Thanos subconsciously
realized that he was not worthy
wielding absolute power and this is the
reason why every attempt the Thanos had
made to to gain absolute power had
always failed Adam warlock goes on to
say that when Thanos first first
appeared in Marvel Comics and he was
attempting to wield the Cosmic Cube that
subconsciously he allowed Captain Marvel
to destroy the Cosmic Cube that when he
had gained the infinity gems for the
first time and combine them into one
massive gem that again he subconsciously
allowed himself to be defeated and that
allowing himself to become one with
eternity and despite the fact that he
could have easily stopped it
allowing nebula to gain the Infinity
Gauntlet was yet again another example
of him subconsciously recognizing that
he's the means to his own defeat that he
recognizes subconsciously that he's not
able to wield absolute power or that
he's not worthy of it and so there's
always this part of his mind that
creates a set of circumstances where by
his defeat will be inevitable Thanos
begins to look into himself and realize
that this is true and so he agrees to to
add a Morlocks plan from here we
transition back to nebula and what we
see is that nebula is speaking with eros
despite the fact that he can still he
still is unable to talk and what nebula
says is that she's beginning to
understand fan OSes hunger for power the
hunger for the infinite might of the
Infinity Gauntlet and the reason why is
because her mind may not necessarily be
as shattered as we were led to believe
now we don't really know if she's been
able to overcome the sudden influx of
all facets of reality but what she tells
eros is that she recognizes that all of
reality is her stew sculpt that she can
do anything she wants to with it and
that she will never again be subjected
to a position where she will be made to
I guess engage in activities that she
would normally be against now this isn't
designed to indicate anything sexual in
the sense that she was made to you know
engage in any kind of sexual activity
it's more of the fact that she would be
subject to somebody else's whims she
would be made to kill other people or
she would be made to conquer other races
instead she could do whatever it is that
she wants and so what she says
is that is a very satisfying thing to us
or to her that is a very satisfying
feeling to know that there's nothing
that can overcome her and what she does
is she kind of gives a demonstration of
the power she possesses by saying that
she's aware that there is going to be a
coming battle that in exactly five
seconds the earthbound superheroes will
be arriving and so what we see is that a
portal opens up almost immediately after
this is said and that the earthbound
superheroes Fire Lord
Thor Doctor Doom the Incredible Hulk and
Drax the destroyer arrive and attempt to
defeat nebula but again she used the
power of the Infinity Gauntlet to
demonstrate that there's nothing they
can do to stop her and what she does is
she encases them and some sort of weird
kind of rocky I guess force for some
kind of rocky form to where all of them
are locked in place and there's nowhere
they can go and so what she says is that
she realizes that this is not simply
just the arbitrary actions of a handful
of superheroes doing what they can to
defeat her that this has all been
orchestrated and that most likely this
has been orchestrated by Thanos and so
what we see is that Adam warlock the
Silver Surfer Thanos and Doctor Strange
up here and that they're going to do
what they can to defeat nebula and again
we'll see this plan come to fruition and
issue number six so as we continue with
Infinity Gauntlet issue number six what
we're gonna see here is this story
beginning to come to a close now that
doesn't necessarily mean that all the
action and everything is going to wind
down in fact we're going to be covering
a lot of ground in a very short amount
of time and so like issue number five
we're gonna be splitting issue number
six into two parts but what we see as
the store begins to unfold or a couple
things the first is that nebula has
imprisoned Thanos in a structure of rock
that he can't escape from but the other
thing and the more important thing here
is that Doctor Strange and the Silver
Surfer are coming to realize something
that Adam warlock exists outside the
realms of chaos and order and in fact
may very well as exists outside of this
reality and Thanos vocalizes this
thought or at the very least he
interprets this thought for us
and tells us that nebula is completely
unaware of Adam warlocks presence she
doesn't know that he's there now the
reason why in terms of why
Thanos knew that Adam warlock was there
but why
nebula doesn't know Adam warlock is here
is because Thanos more or less tells for
this Thanos tells nebula that sure her
intellectual capacity is not up to task
for wielding the Infinity Gauntlet that
in fact she's not able to tap into its
full power and that if she was she would
have immediately known that Adam warlock
was there even if on some kind of
sensory level even if she couldn't
physically see him she would have been
able to read his thoughts or she would
have known what he was thinking now the
fact that nebula can't see Adam warlock
is an extremely important thing and this
will become a major issue later on
although it won't necessarily be in the
form that you think it is but what we
see is that Thanos again continues to
taut nebula he tells nebula that she
doesn't have the vision to properly
exploit the infinity gems and nebula
asks him whether or not he believes he
does and Thanos says yes he says look at
what it was that he was able to
accomplish so far using the infinity
gems now this is really interesting when
it comes to nebula because nebula
describes his actions as of killing off
half the life in the universe in a very
sarcastic way indicating to us that this
is something that she finds appalling
now whether or not this is because
nebula is trying to step into the role
of a good guy here or because nebula is
on the inside a good guy instead of a
villain is not something that's
explained to us but I would go as far as
to say that nebula when you consider her
previous actions in the Marvel Comics
especially when it came to eliminating
the Nova Corps is not necessarily a good
person but the idea of eliminating half
the life in the universe is something
that would be considered
incomprehensible to all but the most
extreme nihilist in the Marvel Comics
one of which is of course Thanos and so
what she says is that the R or the reign
of Thanos in the universe with regards
to his possession of the Infinity
Gauntlet is something that cannot be
allowed to stand and that she's going to
use the Infinity Gauntlet to more or
less set everything back to rights but
what we also see here is
Adam warlock is signaling to dr. strange
silently and again this is Adam warlock
taking precautions to is to ensure that
nebula doesn't know that he's there and
so Doctor Strange uses his magic to do
something although at the moment we
don't know what that is but what we see
is that nebula
uses the Infinity Gauntlet to set
everything back to the way it was before
now with the things that are coming up
with the things that are going to be
taking place I'm curious to see whether
or not you would be able to predict them
because what we're going to be seeing is
that things are going to be changing in
such a way that some very interesting
circumstances are going to arise but
what we see is that as a result of
nebula setting everything back to the
way it was before that of course half
the life in the universe is destroyed
I'm sorry as I restored but with
everything being restored to 24 hours
prior nebula s 1006 planes it to us
reverts back into the previous form that
she had when she was a husk of a being
and so Thanos
again allows his arrogance to like get
the better of him as he begins to brag
as he begins to more or less taut nebula
and say that when she has the power of
godhood she should be careful because
whatever is whatever it is that she
wishes for will come true
and so she has to exercise some measure
of forethought but before thousands is
able to seize the Infinity Gauntlet from
her nebula restores herself back to the
way she was before and again what she
does is she allows her arrogance to get
the better of her as she begins to taunt
Thanos and re imprison Thanos and saying
that the mistake that he made was
allowing himself to be arrogant was
allowing himself to believe that because
she had been referred back to her former
form that she would not be able to
revert herself back or I guess restore
herself back to normal but what we also
see is that Adam warlock appears to be
reaching for the Infinity Gauntlet now
what it is that he intends to do here is
something we're not entirely sure of
although we're more or less led to
believe that maybe he's going to take
this chance while she's talking just
strip her of the Infinity Gauntlet but
what what Adam warlock does here is it
seems as though he touches the Infinity
Gauntlet he touches the the Jim on the
back of the hand and when he does the
Silver Surfer is blasted with some form
of energy and what we also see is that
as a reason
her actions with restoring everything
back to the way it was before that the
shrine of mistress death is no longer
there and so they're more or less just
standing on an asteroid which presumably
was what Fano city used to create the
shrine of mistress death and again
nebula is demonstrating the fact that
she doesn't know that Adam warlock was
here in the fact that she doesn't know
that he's left that he's no longer in
the scene anymore and so what she asks
is how it is that Doctor Strange and the
Silver Surfer are still there when
presumably they should have been
destroyed and so what what she
recognizes here what she more or less
theorizes here is that this presumably
was due to the actions of Doctor Strange
this was due to the actions of him
intervening against her will and so what
she does is she imprisons the hands of
Doctor Strange to keep him from being
able to use his his magic but what we
see phenols commenting on here is
telling nebula there was another error
in judgment that she had yet again
screwed up then that that it's something
that she has been fortunate about so far
that the errors in her judgment haven't
necessarily been major but what she's
about to learn is the fact that when she
set everything back to 24 hours prior
that she didn't fully think it through
and the reason why is because 24 hours
prior to the current events the cosmic
entities were not imprisoned they were
still free and so what we see is that
the cosmic entities have now been
released from their bonds and more or
less what's going to take place is an
attempt by the cosmic entities to
destroy nebula but what we see is that
we transition back to to the soul world
to inside of the soul gym with Adam
warlock and the Silver Surfer and it
appears as though when the Silver Surfer
was struck by some form of energy from
the gauntlet that it may not necessarily
have been a killing blow from nebula
more so than Adam warlock entering the
soul gym and pulling the Silver Surfer
in with him and what the Silver Surfer
asks Adam warlock here is why they're
back in Soul world why they're back
inside of the the soul gym and what Adam
warlock says here is that his power is
greatest within the soul gym that he is
bound to the soul gym in ways that he's
not fully understanding of but that it's
it's such a bind that it
allows him to utilize his full potential
now the reason for this goes all the way
back to the very beginnings of Adam
warlock when he was given the sole Jim
by the High Evolutionary in an attempt
to to take back the counter-earth but
that's a course of story that we're not
necessarily gonna get into but what we
see Adam warlock saying here is I guess
explaining to the Silver Surfer what he
had previously explained to Thanos or
what we were already aware of that in
order for Adam warlock to successfully
bring an end to the Infinity Gauntlet
event that the Infinity Gauntlet had to
change hands that it had to leave Thanos
his hands and go into the hands of
somebody else now whether or not it was
going to be nebula or whether it had to
be somebody else's something that's not
explained to us and in this instance I
don't really think it really matters but
what Adam warlock says is that nebulous
confusion here the fact that she is
overwhelmed for the most part due to the
I guess sensory input of the of the
Infinity Gauntlet of all the the facets
of reality
in addition to her recognition of
newfound power let her in a place where
it was very easy to take advantage of
that it was very easy to use that to
their advantage and so what we see is
that the Silver Surfer realizes that
Adam warlock and knew that Thanos was
going to lose the Infinity Gauntlet
and so the question is what are they
gonna do now what's going to take place
and Adam warlock simply says that he's
going to do what needs to be done and
that in order for this to succeed he's
going to need the Silver Surfer as a
spiritual anchor from here we transition
back to nebula and what we see is that
Galactus and Eon and the Celestials and
very other various other cosmic beings
are using their power to attempt to
overpower nebula and again nebula is
able to use the Infinity Gauntlet even
if only on a base level and Thanos
explains this to us the analyst tells us
that even a a bumbling idiot for the
most part would be able to use the
extreme power of the Infinity Gauntlet
to over.i the power of the cosmic
entities just because of the fact that
even on a subconscious level they would
simply just not want to be defeated and
so the Infinity Gauntlet would exercise
that power accordingly but what we learn
that again Thanos is commenting on the
fact that nebula using the infinite
power of the Infinity Gauntlet is able
to easily overpower the cosmic entity
she's able to defeat them readily and
what we see is that for the most part
the cosmic entities appear to be
entirely imprisoned they appear to be
cast into some form of stone and
completely locked up and what we also
see taking place here is that nebula is
more or less stating that her reign of
supremacy is just beginning that her
reign of omnipotence has just started
and that she's going to be effectively
taking over everything now what we see
is that she's telling Thanos that he is
going to be able to bear witness to a
new astral dynasty he's going to be able
to bear witness to the new reality that
she is creating and that there's going
to be a whole new era assured in with
regards to the earth-616 universe then
we see Fano saying let there be
something and Adam warlock says
disharmony and this is very interesting
here because what Adam warlock has done
here is he's more or less merged himself
with the soul Jim and by merging himself
with the soul Jim he has reached out to
the other five gems and when he reached
out to the other five infinity gems he
forced them to feed back on to nebula
and when this happened the Infinity
Gauntlet became more than nebula could
bear and so nebula through the Infinity
Gauntlet down and so at this point
there's no one in possession of absolute
power everybody has a base set of
abilities at this point we learned what
it was a dr. strange was doing when he
was using his powers and what he had
done is that when everything was set
back to normal that the earthbound
superheroes had all been restored and
they were set back to their previous
forms and so he's called in some of the
more prominent members some of the more
powerful and strong members of the
earthbound superheroes which of course
include Eric Masterson his Thor Drax the
destroyer and the Incredible Hulk
along with eros and he opens a portal to
allow them to enter but what we also see
here is that as that Thanos has broken
free of his binds and for the most part
this is a very interesting set of
circumstances because what we're going
to be seeing is that while Doctor
Strange uses his power to
attempt to confine the Infinity Gauntlet
that Nebula knocks him off guard and
when she does the the bobble or I guess
the bubble that encloses the Infinity
Gauntlet goes away and so we see in
effect this mad dash for absolute power
we see everybody rushing to try to gain
this Infinity Gauntlet we see that the
Incredible Hulk is considering the
Infinity Gauntlet for himself eros is
trying to grab the gauntlet Thanos is
trying to grab the gauntlet and jaxa
destroyers trying to beat up the
Incredible Hulk
what we also see is that amidst the
conflict amidst the fray that Adam
warlock re-emerges from the soul Jim and
when he does he takes possession of the
Infinity Gauntlet and he simply says let
the conflict in and what's really
intriguing about this is that this is
one of the four most pivotal panels or
one of the four most pivotal moments in
Marvel Comics and is one of the most
recognized moments and Marvel Comics
simply because it heralds the end of the
Infinity Gauntlet event and ushers in
the story of warlock and the Infinity
watch but what we see as as we continue
here is that Adam warlock begins to take
on this mantle begins to take on this
role of trying to achieve godhood as
best he can of trying to more or less
become a perfect God in his eyes and he
says that he will deal with everything
that has taken place in his own fashion
and initially people are a little
skeptical here people are a little
unsure Thanos says that the gauntlet
inherently belongs to him and Adam
warlock replies by saying that he would
simply lose it again because he doesn't
really desire it nebula says that the
path of the gauntlet belongs to her and
the question she asked Adam warlock is
what right does he have to power what
right does he have to the Infinity
Gauntlet and Adam warlock simply says
the Infinity Gauntlet is in his
possession and that that's right enough
and so what we see had a Morlock saying
is that his power with the Infinity
Gauntlet is a claim that they would also
they would all do well not to dispute
and that he is going to more or less set
everything to the way it's supposed to
be now what we'll see in Infinity
Gauntlet issue number six part two is we
will pick up with what all
going to happen after Adam warlock gains
the Infinity Gauntlet what is it he does
here and whether or not Adam warlock
will actually be able to demonstrate
himself as a true and fair God or
whether he will succumb to the
corruption that the Infinity Gauntlet
I guess involves with regards to people
who are willing
so with the second half of Infinity
Gauntlet issue number six we get a
conclusion to this story we get an end
to the Infinity Gauntlet event and
picking up where we left off with
Infinity Gauntlet issue number six part
one what we saw was that Adam warlock
had attained the Infinity Gauntlet for
himself and that he had promised to be a
fair and just God and so what we see
Adam warlock saying here is that he
promises to use this power wisely that
he promises not to abuse this power in
the same fashion that nebula or Thanos
had and what's really interesting here
is that for the most part Adam warlock
seems very sincere here he seems as
though it really is his intention to be
a good guy and the question that the
incredible hulk has is what are they
gonna do about that oh s--- and nebula
what's going to happen with them now
interaction a story of course being a
being that was created for the
destruction of Thanos takes it upon
himself to say the Thanos is his that
he's going to try to kill thanos here
but of course Thanos is easily able to
overpower both the Incredible Hulk and
Drax the destroyer from here we switched
to Thanos saying that he's activated
some kind of a thermonuclear device on
his belt line and that it's set to
activate in about 15 seconds and Silver
Surfer asks why why would fan OHS kill
himself and that oh says that for him
death is preferential to imprisonment
now he doesn't necessarily explicitly
say this but I would even go as far as
to speculate that for Thanos if he were
to die he would find absolute happiness
within the realm of mistress death but
again every instance that we've seen
with Thanos where he has gone
after mistress death has always been an
attempt to be by her side to be her
equal moreso than a person who simply
just exists inside her realm and so what
we see is that Eric Masterson takes the
hammer of Thor and hits Thanos with it
and when he does stano's is knocked away
from the newly restored shrine of
mistress death and out into the depths
of space where he explodes presumably
killing him and this is what everybody
takes saw and everybody takes on this
mantle that Thanos has been killed that
Thanos is now dead he's no longer part
of this conflict anymore and so we see
that euro-step
Suppan says that as AZ member or
represent a representative of the state
of Titan that he's taking custody of
nebula for himself and euros has grounds
to do this because again as far as
everybody here knows nebula is a real
relative of Thanos and so by extension
she's a relative of Eros and so eros is
for the most part just settling family
issues here and so the Adam warlock
agrees with this Adam warlock says
that's fine and he teleports eros Drax
the destroyer nebula away but then also
teleports the Incredible Hulk away
presumably back to the planet Earth and
so the only people that we have left are
the Silver Surfer Erik Masterson and dr.
strange and the question that's asked
here by by the Silver Surfer is why why
are they still here when everybody else
has been sent away and out of war Locke
says that they have gazed into his into
the depths of his heart they know him
the way nobody else does and for the
most part Adam warlock is saying here
that they are the only individuals who
know him well enough that when he says
that he will be a God who can be trusted
that he means it and so he sends them
forward to tell other people this is
true and again this is very much tapping
into the element of Adam warlock
representing a Jesus Christ like figure
in Marvel Comics because again if you go
back and watch our discussion on Adam
warlock if we go back and and listen to
what it was that we were saying that
Adam warlock was introduced to us as a
christ-like figure he had simply just
emerged one day he was created he was I
guess crucified by man beast on the
counter earth during that storyline and
of course he had resurrected himself on
several occasions and so this is tapping
back into that in the same way that
Jesus had for informed his disciples
that he was truly the Son of God and to
go forth and to spread his word that
Adam warlock is doing much the same
thing and for the most part what we see
is that these uh superheroes are kind of
questioning this they're saying is this
really true can they really go forward
and say that Adam warlock is a fair and
true God because as Doctor Strange says
absolute power corrupts absolutely and
Adam warlock
asks them if the idea of replacing their
chaos the chaos that is their lives with
order if it would be something
unpalatable and again what we see is
that they're reacting in such a way to
where for them this is scary that not
only would their lives be irrevocably
changed if Adam warlock chose to do so
but that Adam warlock looks at them as
chaotic beings and that his role is to
replace their chaos with order to in
effect make the universe the way he sees
fit and so for them they look at this as
though he's taking the first few steps
towards becoming corrupted by the power
of the Infinity Gauntlet
but Adam warlock is able to quell their
concerns to a degree he says that the
distance between who he was now or who
he was then and who he is now is
something insurmountable that not even
he realizes the differences and that he
thought that he could speak with them
and tell them that he would be fair he
thought that he could demonstrate that
he would be a fair god but that it
doesn't seem as though they are willing
to to buy into this cause and so what we
see is that Adam warlock teleports them
away at this point we switch to Adam
warlock 60 days into the future with
Gamora and pip and what Adam warlock
tells pip is that they're going to meet
someone they're going to go on a journey
and he says for the most part that this
is something that's happened time and
time again and so what it seems is that
Adam warlock has manipulated the time
gem to travel 60 years into the future
on several occasions to see if it's
possible for things to turn out
differently but what he tells us is that
it always turns out the same way and so
what we see is they're walking along is
that it appears that the Thanos is
standing in the cornfields the Thanos is
assembly just waiting their arrival but
when they get to it they realize it is
simply just a scarecrow wearing his suit
and Adam warlock comments on this and
says that it's an empty shell of what
was that it appears as though Thanos has
cast aside his old mantle of attempting
to usurp absolute power and seems to
maybe just be living a quiet life and
indeed that's what we learned we learned
that when they approach a house
relatively close to the corn fields that
Thanos emerges wearing some kind of garb
some kind of maybe monk-like garb or a
an outfit that simply just
allows him relative comfort and he tells
Adam warlock that he should have known
that it would be him that he would come
for him eventually and Adam more like
more or less just greets Thanos as a
friend here at their very least if not a
friend as a person who's certainly not
an enemy
and so what Adam warlock says is that
there are no secrets from him having
absolute knowledge and absolute power
within the universe grants him the
knowledge of knowing what all was going
on in the universe at that very moment
and so Thanos comments and says that the
memory of having absolute power is very
dim for him and that he asked Adam
warlock why he had waited so long to
gain vengeance and again Adam warlock
comments and says why is it that he
always asks the same question indicating
that this is repeated itself on several
occasions that Adam warlock has traveled
into the future several times and that
this circumstance always plays out the
same way and Thanos seems to recognize
this Thanos says that he supposes that
he always asks the same question and
that is a bit confusing which of course
tells us that Thanos well he doesn't
necessarily recall every facet of the
Infinity Gauntlet event at the very
least remembers what it was like to hold
that absolute power and what Adam
warlock tells Thanos is that he's
looking for some advice more more likely
advice on how to wield the Infinity
Gauntlet effectively and Thanos simply
says to either endure it or to surrender
to its power and Adam warlock says this
really isn't the kind of comfort he was
looking for now what it was that he was
looking for with Thanos is something
that we actually don't learn we don't
learn what it was that he was trying to
gain from Thanos here or what it was he
was trying to get Thanos to say all we
know is that he went to Thanos for
advice on what to do and Thanos gave him
a couple words that didn't really seem
to comfort him that well and so for the
most part Adam warlock Gamora and pip
take their leave they choose to go ahead
and leave Venice to his thoughts and
what we see is it for the most part
Thanos is simply just living a quiet
life here that after everything that's
gone on after everything that has taken
place at Thanos is taking this time to I
guess to collect himself to decide what
his next move is going to be whether or
not he's still going to continue his
path for trying to gain absolute power
again or if he is simply just going to
try to live a quiet life and again
touching back on Thanos his character
within the the Marvel
universe we learn of course later on
that Thanos goes after the heart of the
universe which of course grants him
absolute power once more but for the
most part we're left with Thanos here on
his personal thoughts as he says that
for the most part he thinks that he came
out on top with this particular event
that Adam warlock is is undergoing a
process that he's undergoing a change
and that he holds a heavy burden and the
fact that he has absolute power and so
he has to constantly be on guard he has
to constantly be vigilant because even
the slightest subconscious thought could
lead to the ruin of all and so again
Thanos says that he doesn't envy Adam
warlock and that at the end of the day
that after everything is all said and
done that Thanos came out on top here
now his statement in terms of coming out
on top is twofold
the first half is that he's managed to
eliminate the burden of absolute power
this is no longer something he has to
deal with and so his mind is at ease but
the other half the second part of this
is that Adam warlock is going to undergo
something called the trial of warlock
whereby he will be called before the
Living Tribunal at the behest of the
cosmic entity eternity along with the
other cosmic entities to determine
whether or not he is capable of being
able to wield the Infinity Gauntlet with
that being said we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end and I really
hope you guys enjoy the Infinity
Gauntlet story it is in fact I would
consider to be one of the absolute best
stories to ever been created in the the
Marvel Comics events with that being
said and we'll catch you guys later
peace
[Music]